Oh God, this is my shot. Don't
fuck this up. Neil Brennan. Oh God.
This is the one,
this episode of the Joe Rogan experience
is brought to you by stamps.com I don't
know if you freaks know this,
but postage rates are scheduled to
increase again starting September. Well,
you know what?
Here's the thing about postage traits.
You can't really complain because how
much would I have to pay you to take a
fucking package across the country?
Would you really do it for 10 bucks? Huh?
Shut your hole.
Would you really send a letter across
the country for less than a dollar?
How dare you fucks.
So don't complain about the postage rates,
but be aware of them that this Sunday,
January 26th the post office is going to
hike that shit up. So the post office,
I'm sure we'll be even more crowded
then usual with everyone buying updated
postage.
But the great thing about having
stamps.com is that stamps.com updates the
posted rates for you automatically.
So you'll always get the exact postage
you need for any letter or package.
Roy, right from your desk. You printed
out right from your home computer.
It's so easy.
It's so much better than going to
the fucking post office itself.
She's this little wheezes
waiting in that ridiculous line,
bringing all your nonsense up to some
lady who doesn't give two female.
What else said about the post office?
Never the right temperature. That's right.
It's always too hot.
I'm going to go always way,
way too hot and always 83 that's just
cause there's too many people in there
that are fuming. They're in
their fucking fuck. Fuck, fuck.
Looking for a pen.
We do generate a lot of body heat
and you give it off like steam.
Um,
stamps.com is a way that you can
do all this stuff from your home.
They give you a digital scale with a
free $55 of postage that you get in the r
he offer, which means if you see
that old school, he microphone,
you click on that bitch and the
upper anterior corner. There you go.
And I'm entering the code word j,
RN and then we'll give you
this $110 special offer
includes $55 free postage and
a digital scale that you want not
to use for mushrooms, Neal Brennan.
Now who would do that and not
kind of a person would do.
That's not what it's for.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything,
click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage.
Type in j r e that stamps.com and enter
in j r e we are also brought to you by
legal zoom and legal zoom is
we know several people used it.
Brian used it to become an
incorporated with death squad.
Aubrey used it for on at.com I I know
at least four or five people that have
used legal zoom instead of actually
going to a lawyer and sitting down and
making an appointment and paying
some exorbitant hourly fee.
Instead of doing that,
you can deal with a lot of legal
shit online with legal zoom.
They can walk you through it.
It's real easy.
You can do things like incorporate form
an LLC for starting at just 99 bucks.
There's not a lawyer alive and
only charges nine $9 an hour.
So if you could do that for a show,
you're saving some money.
You can also get a last wheel for
just 69 bucks or living trust,
power of attorney,
more legal zoom gets the job done right.
Nine out of 10 customers would recommend,
recommend would recommend the
service to their family and friends.
And that's a lot.
When you think about legal shit,
nine hundred ten nine out of 10 if it's
like nine of 10 people say these shoes
don't hurt your feet. I don't know. I
want tenant. I don't, you know what?
I don't trust that the, I don't
trust that 10th person. Yeah,
at 10 persons always a creep.
If you just think about like if you're
at a football from jail, if you will.
Thank you very much. You
did. You stepped in big.
If you're ever at a football game
and you know, you could say, oh,
there's fucking people that gave her ass
holes. It's not the people at the game.
It's usually like a couple people.
If you're at a fucking stadium
that has 50,000 people in,
there's a hundred cunts. Okay. And
it doesn't mean that you know Philly,
that's fine as bad come to Philander
cuts Philly give more violent,
I wouldn't call them cottons.
There are a lot more violent than cons.
They break your legs, they don't
fuck around. They open with that.
You get personalize affordable
service that you can trust.
And that's why they earned an a plus
from the better business bureau.
That's huge for real.
Uh, in the past 12 years,
over 2 million Americans have used legal
zoom and they've saved a ton of money.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they can connect you with a third
party attorney and they can provide you
with self health services.
So if you panic,
if you're in the middle of using
legal zoom and you're like, fuck,
this is not working, I'm going
to jail, they can connect to you.
It was an independent attorney.
Uh, so don't worry about it.
You're going to be okay. But it couldn't
be any easier. Brian, you've used it.
It's easy to use. Very easy. I think I
did it drunk. Remember? That's right.
Probably naked,
naked and drunk and it's still legal,
which is awesome because if you show
up at your attorney's office naked and
drunk, you're going to jail. This is
the opposite. You're not going to jail.
You're protecting yourself.
Okay.
And her in the Codeword
Rogan in the referral box at
checkout and save some cash
senior Rita's and you've seen yours.
They can get you a
copyright patents trademark.
Their online process.
Couldn't be easier.
League goes zoom.com code word Rogan.
That's,
that's the referral.
That's me bitches.
And we're also brought to
you by [inaudible] dot com
that's, Oh and, and I it,
if you've heard this podcast
before, you've heard this
fucking commercial before.
There's no other way to do it.
But to ensure you that on it is literally
the best shit that we can find in
terms of strength and
conditioning equipment like
kettle bells or gotten roped.
God, when you hugged me today,
there was an extra form. Yeah,
it was extra force in the heart, you
know, Brennan battle ropes, weight vests,
which you have to be careful. Let me tell
you this. Weight vests and running, um,
be really careful about that.
I know you've probably seen videos
with MMA fighters doing that,
but when you tend to get exhausted,
you,
you really should be really careful
about running with weight vests on your,
you're loading your body in an
unnatural way. Point this out a lot.
That's how Martin Lawrence
caught a coma is a really,
he was running in the valley.
No, no. He was on drugs.
He was in a winter coat. No, no, no, no.
That wasn't no wait vast. He wasn't. No,
but he was in a goose down coat
in the valley. 90 degree weather.
He's trying to lose weight. It's crack,
bro. Cochlear has a crack. Didn't help.
It doesn't, it definitely didn't
help. Um, we, we sell these,
we have two different types. Kettlebells
we just started selling recently. Um,
primal bowels,
which are all done in apes,
the various great apes like gorilla,
orangutan chimp.
And how I regretted not having
one of those. You'll get one.
Just tell me what you want and I'll
have to send to you. Thank you.
You can't use the grill cause
you're not quite manly enough,
but I'll send you a housing. Mikey. I was
45 pounds. The gorillas, 72 pounds, sir.
You're not manly.
I'm not manly enough to use a gorilla,
but for a few exercises I'm going to
be honest with you people and that's,
there's a reason for this honesty,
not just self deprecation,
but also to enforce that. If you're
going to do something like kettlebells,
please, please, please start slow,
start slow with a weight
that you can actually handle.
When you throw in kettle bells around,
you are swinging big fucking
heavy iron balls. All right?
They're legit.
They really are solid metal and they
will fuck you up if you use them wrong.
You can tear joints, you can hurt your
back. You can do all kinds of things.
If you do it wrong, what you should
do is get a small kettle bell,
like 35 pounds of, you're a
big, strong manly man like me.
It's plenty especially to start out
with and it's not like something you're
going to outgrow because there are certain
exercises like the DVD that we sell,
which is the extreme kettlebell cardio
workout with Keith Webber. Got DVD,
kicks my ass with 35 pound kettle bells.
It's,
it's fucking tremendous and these things
will be here long after you're gone.
They will be here after the apocalypse.
The fucking aliens will land and they
will find a giant metal gorilla head and
they will think that these fucking pink
dummies with their bang sticks and their
text messages were worshiping,
worshiping chimps and gorillas.
That's what they're doing that that, that
fucking kettle bell will kick your ass.
That workout. The extreme kettlebell
cardio workout one I haven't done.
Number two, they have a two DVD, which
is supposed to be just as vicious,
if not more, but look at that sexy
stud, Keith Weber on the cover. Goddamn,
if I looked like him,
I felt so happy about it being him.
You would love to meet him and to let
go and you just start producing estrogen
and nimble. Start dripping on your shirt.
Beaver girls smell you and they're like,
what are you fucking smell like milk
bitch. Fuck. And then they lose,
they lose confidence in you
because a man made you grow milk
on it.com oh and and I t um,
as as far as the supplements go,
we have mostly most of the stuff that
we buy is shit that either Aubrey or I
already use already enjoy things like
we have the best hemp protein powder you
can get.
Hemp force is made out of the most
expensive shit that we can get from Canada
and it is really delicious.
We F we sweeten it with Stevia so
it has very little sugar in it.
There's like one gram of sugar.
How much protein?
30 grams of protein per
serving per serving. Yeah.
How many servings per plant based protein?
He goes right through your body.
Nice and easy. It doesn't make you
fart your brains out. Like, wait, we,
I'd love whey protein but I
find that way makes me fart.
How much is this a hemp force is,
oh,
that's a good question. Until you're
right here, I should know this.
4,495 per container, you
know, it's fucked, man.
We could make it a lot cheaper, but
we, uh, we can't grow it in America.
They don't let us there.
They're starting to write now.
It's going to be really interesting to
see what happens with Colorado and uh,
what happens with Seattle,
with Washington state,
because if they can successfully
start producing hemp,
which is not psychoactive by the way,
we're not talking about growing pot
flavored chocolate or anything with
chocolate and vanilla. Correct. Both
of them is flavored with Stevia,
both of them with Maka coat,
raw cocoa.
It's the most nutritious shit that we
know how to put together or to buy or that
we can find. Um, like I said,
we buy the most expensive,
best hemp powder we can get.
Our philosophy is just tried to
give you shit that we use and,
and shit that actually can benefit you.
And in terms of the controversial
things like new mood,
which I actually found out about five
HTP from the man standing across the
street from me or the table rather Neil
Brennan told me about five HTP back.
You're the guy I didn't, I had no idea
about it. And I started investigating it.
And um, we created new mood with
five HTP and l trip to fan as well,
which converts to five HTP.
Sure does.
So the idea is how long
has it been on the site?
We've had it for awhile and
that's probably the most part,
one of the most popular,
least controversial.
The Alpha brain is the most controversial
because Alpha brain is a nootropic and
it's about stimulating neural activity
and creating Le Giving your body the
nutrients it needs,
the building blocks to create newer trend
neurotransmitter's and there's science
behind it and there's,
you know,
there's been studies done on the various
ingredients, but it's still, it's still,
for a lot of people,
they see things and they cry bullshit
and for good reason because a lot of
things are bullshit.
What's not bullshit nutrients and what's
not bullshit is a science behind these
new trends offices explained
at [inaudible] dot com and
we also offer a 30 pill,
90 day 100% money back guarantee where
you don't even have to return the product
to just say this didn't work and
then you get your money back.
We are only selling you shit
that I know is effective.
That I know is excellent. The best
stuff we can find and we can sell,
and if you use the Codeword Rogan, you
will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Jesus Louise's Neal Brennan
could be you be any sweeter.
Hit The music
well good.
Joe Rogan podcast
podcast pastor
television standup
comedian friend Neil,
broken render show friends.
I got a hot tweet right now fucking
bragging about bright red. I'm trending.
I literally died a fucking
special on Saturday, not trending.
I have some stupid Richard Sherman tweet.
Literally Neal Brennan is trending in
Houston, Chicago and the United States.
It's that easy.
Boom.
One Good Joe Kuhn is all that separates
any of us from trending that it's true.
One good joke or one really controversial
Dick picture that is one of those.
And Boom, you're trending Neal
Brennan, you're out there.
You've got the right phone down though.
Don't you know add on me. No, I'm not. No,
I won't have to your computer. So I feel
a little jealous cause we work here.
Actually, I'm actually trying to
put together a show. Oh my fault.
You guys are building.
No,
I mean it looks like we're just
fucking around and going online.
Most of the time you are. Sometimes
it's like life, man. Okay.
Fucking around as a part of life.
Life is a part of the show. It's not,
don't be too rigid. When you're
rigid, you miss possibilities.
You know what I'm saying? Go on. And
we know that in any wrong, come on.
I'm the king of WHO's more flexible,
was more flexible than Neil Brennan.
Are you flexible? I wonder who is more
physically flexible. Me. Are you, oh,
I'm way more flexible. Okay. For sure.
Can you do the splits or anything?
Can't it really? Fuck you
always surprise me. Well,
I did taekwondo from the
time it was a baby. Yeah.
You are you really flexible
and you unusually kind of like,
I can, I don't have, it's like I don't
have a lot of tendons or something.
You're lacking pass, so you
just, yeah, I didn't do, yeah,
there's a picture of me doing this split.
See, boom. I'm not just talking shit.
Go Neal Brennan.
I'm just crazy.
I was texting me like Rick
variation there as well.
Even impossible with your man Dick.
It was like sitting like it.
They just feel good. You've got to pull
it up. You pull it up and then you,
you buck your hips forward and
then you let your Dick drop. Yeah,
but you don't want to do a split on your
Dick. That's really bad for your Dick.
It's a lot of pressure. You Dick's not
especially with like a hardwood floor.
Think about that. You're squashing
your dick on a hardwood floor.
You could fucking hurt your
balls that way as well. Um, yeah.
My dog almost hurts my balls
a lot. Your dog. Yeah. No.
My three year old jumps on my balls. Yeah,
my dog jumps on my balls all the time.
I let her jump on top. She like,
uh, if I'm lying on the bed,
she'll come up and grab my hands and
just jump up and stomp on my abs. I,
and I'm like,
it's a good ab workout just to get
a little kid to go fucking crazy.
But occasionally she'll miss the amps,
the cocker room.
I'd like to open with a good ball story.
Buddy of mine won't say who it was.
Uh, having sex with a
girl, a titty fucking her,
which this is my buddy who just likes to
titty. Fuck, but I don't know who that,
who am I to judge?
I have zero interest in titty
fucking that's fifth place to me.
That's my boy.
I know what you're doing.
You're just setting up a nice titty
fucking scenario later. I will,
under no circumstances will I tinny fuck
any woman who comes to the valley and
there's going to be a girl after
your show holding delicious tits,
like absolutely perfect ones.
And I will not have a challenge.
I challenge her on,
what'd you say about titty fucking and
they're going to be big and real buddy of
mine titty. Fucking okay.
Uh, he's about to finish.
He says to the girl,
squeeze them together. Okay.
She grabs his nuts and squeezes
them as hard as she can.
Comes like Bob came.
He came come and blood.
Oh my God.
She broke them. Yeah. What's
crazy bitch? Yeah, it,
that's a good old fashioned miscue mean.
That's a three's company.
Miscommunication. She's managing
city fucking her. I think she,
I sh I don't, you can't like rape
titty. Fuck somebody. Yes you can.
Yes you can. If you have a strong
mouth, they let you to the fuck.
I'm just so that you'll get off him.
A lot of people that would do that.
What would that be? That would be
bloody though. She broke his dick.
She'd squeezed the wrong,
something happened. It's all
wrong. It's this, she, she's,
she was supposed to push
her tits together. Let's ups
terrible miscommunication.
That's at three's company
style. Miscommunicate come
and knock on their door.
That is a squeezing together.
I thought you meant something else.
Although he then went to the nurse,
then he went to the doctor the next
day and she rubbed at like Mri Jelly or
whatever, the uh, cat scan
jelly on his dick. And he said,
that's one of the best sexual
experiences he's ever had in his life.
What's always cold. I would imagine that
would feel really good on your Dick.
Yeah. Wow. And what did, what happened
when the cat scan is Dick? I think he,
I think he just had to not use it for a
bit. Imagine if the girl was Cass County,
his Dick, and she's watched, she's
doing it just going like God damn
dear penthouse times.
Has anybody ever gone to the doctor and
started getting the Dick cat scan and
then just start fucking the
doctor? You know, that's happened.
I know a guy who, who, uh,
was staying at the four seasons and fuck
the made Mike favor men fucked a maid.
I mean, he told us that story
favor men fucked and he's such,
wasn't even attractive. But she walked in
on him jerking off and she was like, oh,
sorry. He's like, shut the door. Come
on in, shut the door, hold on it.
And he said that he didn't even talk.
They just started banging. You don't,
you're not famous video of the guy that
sets up his laptop and then I records
maid's coming in while he's jacking off.
So like just wait. Yeah, explain that.
Say that like we know the thing that you
watch every day before you do anything.
There's this hilarious guy and you could
find that he fucked.com is one of the
websites that has it and it's just this
guy that puts this laptop here and he
puts headphones on. He just waits for
the maid. And then when she comes in,
he records like him jerking off and he,
has he been looking at her or
was he looking at his screen?
I know he's just like,
you can't see his face.
You just see it's from his Dick
[inaudible] the front door.
So you're just like the maids
come in one after another,
one after another and they're like,
they all do different things.
Most of them were like,
oh my God. So sorry.
So I'm just sit there and
just slowly turn around it.
But his mission was to actually have
somebody like fuck him or give him a blow
job. He just released a second
one where it finally at the end,
I almost don't want to give it away.
I made does come up and just start staring
at it and then slowly walks up and he
goes, Oh, do you want this?
And, and he goes, yes I do.
And the guys starts sucking him off on
the video. No, it was a male may miss you.
I promise you the twist
is that there's a male may
no. Listen, I don't know if you know this,
but I used to be on fear factor. Right?
I know about reality TV
and I don't buy that.
Please watch the videos act.
I kinda watching guys talk a guy's Dick.
I know what you're doing. What you're
doing is trying to trick me trying to,
you're trying to convert us bro.
You know you don't know me as well as
you think you know me. I'm not that dumb.
Okay.
How dare you.
Well if trying to trick me to have like
500 other videos of women turning them
down over and over and over
again, and then he, I would not,
I would be on your boat to thinking it
was fake. But it's, he's been doing this.
I've known if I put that
[inaudible] is the one of
the worst detectives in the
history of Scotland Yard.
The police, he's following bad
leads. Gosh, really? He said, yeah.
Inspector Crusoe. His first video
came out like three to five years ago.
Then he's gotta be true
close, your honor. Yeah.
There's no need to further investigate.
We've got this one locked up. Uh,
I don't pull it up. Nobody wants to,
I don't want to watch God blow a guy.
I'm proud to say I was on one
of these sites. You have a day,
and I don't know if
anybody else does this,
where you'll PDR periodically check
in to make sure you're not gay.
Watch 15 seconds of male porn and
just go like, nope, still not good.
I'm still, as of last week, I'm still
not good. I think I'm out of the woods.
You know.
I think I'm officially out of the woods.
You remember the old Kinison bit
about that? It was a, he's like a,
they say every band's kind
of homosexual fantasy.
So I'm sitting around the house the other
day going over my fantasies because if
there's one in there I want to know.
I want to fucking know.
Yeah. I didn't like the idea of a guy
there was, I think he got was blown.
Another guy. Stubble. That's
what Bob just like stubble.
There's a lot that she bought it.
I don't want stubble anywhere near
precious. Well, men are crazy
and they're violent. And uh,
there were also that way if they're gay,
straight man,
crazy and violent and straight
straight men and gay men. They're,
the only difference is one
of them likes boys. Okay.
So the idea of that being
hot and sexy, uh, uh,
it's like getting blown by crazy
chimp. You know, I don't trust dudes.
Some Studley muscular dude
who suck on my deck. It's,
I can just rip it off and
throw it away and go, ha ha ha.
I like how you went a little crazy
on a big muscular guy going, hey,
fucking Harry perfectly Harry chess.
Perfectly Harry. Not Too much.
It's trims it a to grow out a little, but
it doesn't get, it doesn't get unkempt.
Yeah, they, they're having a good time
over there. I got to say the case. Yeah.
The gays have a weird life because
if it wasn't for the persecution,
it's pretty God damn sweet.
If you think about it,
like if we all men and women,
okay.
And this is coming from a guy who has
kids and loves having kids. However,
there's a weirdness to having sex with
men and women because it can possibly
result in a child. That weirdness
is eliminated with gay people.
It's just fucking,
and there's no Yang.
It's all Yin or Yang. No Yen, one of
those, whichever it is a hard one.
There's that.
Well, there is a bit of a Yin Yang in
them. There's, there's a little bit of,
there's a bottom top issue.
Yeah.
But there's what the issue isn't what
a man wants versus what a woman wants.
They're both men.
So the weirdness like the
trying to figure out women,
especially like when you're young,
one of the weirdest things is just the
idea of trying to think the way a woman
thing. You think the way that guy thinks
you think everything's going to be fine.
And like I remember when I was young and
I just started dating when I was like a
teenager.
I would talk to girls the way I would
talk to my friends and they would get
upset and they would think
you're crazy and can't do it.
You cannot change your language
completely. Change your language,
change your approach, change the way you
guys can fuck around with each other.
And we assume that we're gonna like laugh
and fuck around with each other back.
And that's what we did.
We insult each other
halfass constantly day.
Do you know that there's a generation
though of girls now that are like Paul
busty and but it's the worst because a,
they're not good at it.
That was me. They're actually ball
busting and seed. You can't hit them back.
So you just have to go like,
yeah, it's crazy. That was stupid.
My shirt was stupid and you
can't go like, hey, by the way,
I could eviscerate you at any point.
I could have you crying and five seconds.
But if they're good at it,
see if they're good at it,
then it doesn't matter if they're a man
or a woman, it becomes irrelevant. Like,
okay, who's, who's really good at it?
Christina Palicki is a great ball buster.
She's all, I believe that she's
Hilarious, but she's good at it.
You know what I mean? And she's also, she
doesn't do it when it's not necessary.
Right. You know, she'll jump in when you
know, when she thinks something's funny.
He's going on just like a comic.
She's just a person that happens to be
funny and that's when you should be able
to ball bus when you're a person.
That's actually funny.
The worst is when you're
getting ballbuster by someone
who's not funny. Yeah.
Then it's not ball busting. It's just
you insulting me and pretending it to do
Joe. Yeah, exactly. And it's not, it's
not that funny, but I'm pretending.
It's funny because I would like to have
sex with you in the next couple hours.
Good at going over.
All the things are ridiculous about me,
so if you say something ridiculous
amount being or stupid that I've done,
I will fucking laugh with.
Oh, I think it's important to
do and it's fun. Yeah. I just,
I think the best,
that's one of my favorite parts
about being friends with comedians.
It's like you're,
I'm getting made fun of on the highest
fucking level and it's a real pleasure.
It's fun. Yeah. It's fun.
Like, what are you? Perfect.
Perfect. Come on. You're an idiot.
I'm an idiot. We're all idiots.
Were all skating through
this fucking Weirdo life.
Don't get so uptight about it.
But there's a big difference between
that when someone's just being funny and
someone's like, just
insulting you. You know,
they didn't just think it's funny to make
fun of you in some way that's not even
humorous. You know? Like, this is weird.
You know? Like what's going on here?
I'm talking about girls that
took a class at UCB or something.
I'll look like an Improv class. I'm going
to turn some about classes. Go ahead.
They don't work.
Um,
I know that they have worked for stand
up a couple of people who's worked,
the standups that were in the phonies,
they began with out how to do comedy,
right?
They figured out how to do comedy,
but you're not going to
figure it out from a class.
What the class does do is it gives you
an opportunity to focus on it and go on
stage and do the material and fuck around.
But that guy can't teach her how to do
college. Oh No. But he can give me an a,
he can force your hand. He
can get you to do it. He can,
he can put you in front of people,
but when they start judging you
take it all with a grand salt.
Take it all with a grain of salt because
you might just figure out how to do it
that way.
If people had caught like say Joey Diaz,
perfect example back when Joey Diaz was
floundering like in the late nineties
and he wasn't doing that well on stage.
Like if people have seen Joey now
he's a destroyer. He's a monster.
But back then he wasn't,
he just hadn't figured it out yet.
What was he doing back then was he was
concerned about other people's opinions.
He wasn't nervous. He didn't feel like
he belonged there. I didn't feel like,
and he gave up one day,
he's a fuck this.
He just somehow or another figured out
how to just be himself on stage. You know,
you've met him, Brian, you, when you met
him, he was already funny. Yeah. Right.
You met him. He was already Joey
Diaz. Right. But before that,
like in the late nineties he
said he was much thinner too.
Was it what he was using and not
use? It could be. It could be.
He just stopped giving a fuck. You know,
the thing, there was a lot going on,
you know? He was also is much more
troubled back then. He just, you know,
I had to come into his own, you know,
as a man, as a comedian, all the above.
But if you gave me advice
back then, that's my point
when he was bombing. Right.
You would, you wouldn't get it.
You would be wrong. You know,
if you told them you're being
too offensive, you're too rude.
What you're saying is not funny. It
makes people uncomfortable. Wrong.
He just needed to figure out how to
do it right. So if you watch him now,
he talks about the exact same shit.
I mean,
Joey Diaz essentially talks
about the exact same shit.
He's always talked about girls assholes.
This guy's a pussy.
Shut your mouth. Suck my
Dick. You know? I mean,
it's just him talking mad shit in
the most hilarious way possible.
And he always did that. It just, it
didn't, hadn't figured it out yet.
Has anyone ever given you good standup
advice? Comics have? Yeah. Yeah.
Comics have given me very good advice.
Can you think of the best that's advice
I ever got is don't say fuck too much.
They say, fuck too much.
You, you over. Fuck.
You use out the word where
it doesn't mean anything.
And it also makes you look like
you're a dummy and what people,
what it is is a lot of times it's a
substitution for the word, uh, for,
for um,
uh,
instead of saying now you say it's
fucking guy with his fucking hair flowing
like fucking Fabio. You know, it's
what you're doing is just doing slots.
Also impossible to know if the joke works.
If you say fucking in
it me the first time,
if you're trying to joke out and
then you're like, I'd rather not say,
and then you get on
stage and you're about to do the
punchline and you're like, you know what,
let me throw in a fuck
here just to be safe.
You should never do that.
But flux when their,
when they belong are crucial because if
you don't say fuck there and I know you
say fuck some times I'm,
I'm missing something.
You can either use fuck or never used.
Fuck. You can either Jim Gaffigan,
Brian Regan it where there's no fucks,
no fucks used.
Or you can drop d as an
interesting theory. Yeah.
Everyone's funny or clean.
That's theory sucks.
Oh absolutely. Here's
his here. He says, okay.
Obviously Bill Cosby,
but he says he's the only guy
who was actually funny or dirty.
Again, his theory, it's reading. What's,
what's Eddie's most memorable? But
Eddie who? Murphy Ice
Cream? Um, well it depends.
Ice Cream. I mean it's probably ice
cream. He fucking you in the ass.
I don't know about that. I
think it's nice car. Yeah.
You literally just looked for
to hit downloads on Youtube.
I think ice cream would be higher.
I think the barbecue would be hires
honeymooners getting fucked in the ass.
I've been looking at you and I know that,
you know,
and I want to fuck you in the
ass. Horrible bit. That was a war.
It was a cartoon or sleep bad,
but that's a bit that I bet he
would disavow today. Yeah. But no,
because he's really good at impressions,
but he does. It's a Shitty, like what are,
they fucked each other in the eyes.
It's like, wow, how you think of that.
But in the context of the series of
bits that he was doing about gay people,
he did it early in his actor.
That's what he did it like in the
first 15 minutes of that special.
It's kind of like you're doing eight,
I'm going to fuck you in the ass.
Well, I'll tell you, man, when I watched
that special, I was in high school,
I was in Newton and it was me and my
buddy Jimmy lawless and John Badaracco and
John's sister was the only girl there
was a real fucking buzz kill because we
felt bad about laughing at some of this
stuff. But we were crying, laughing,
crying, laughing is the first time I'd
ever seen Eddie Murphy Raw. I was like,
God damn, that was
funny. Or not delirious.
Rod Ron wasn't quite as good. I don't, I
don't feel, I feel like delirious was the
[inaudible] wasn't quite as good,
but they both, I think that,
I think the lyrics has the, the barbecue,
which is an amazing bit. Oh yeah.
And someone pointed out to me when he's
finished, so one of the audience yells,
do what again,
good side for a bit.
That's hilarious. And Ice Cream,
ice cream and the barbecue.
I had both thought so I would, so that's
rocks theory that every and Chapin,
he would say Chappelle's best bid
is like baby on the corner. Um,
Chappelle's best bit is about this to be
the creation of AIDS. I totally agree.
I always say,
I always say Chappelle.
He's the only person on earth
who would side with the monkey
I saw.
So it's a really funny bit because
like you have a try to fuck a monkey
will be to to fuck.
I'm like
no, exactly. Monkeys or people
you don't, you don't fuck month.
You don't feel like I'm a
stay home tonight and the
stigma and bubbles is fixing
to give me a foot job or what?
I wonder if anybody has ever really fucked
a live monkey mean you'd have to kill
it to get the fuck up.
I think you,
well you maybe just give
it some wine or something.
You got to club it over their head.
There's no other way a monkey's going to
let you fuck it. They're going to rip.
You don't think so?
I don't think so.
Like I would just like a
fucking little shoulder Magee.
If you have a little shoulder monkey,
imagine how big your Dick
Looks to that monkey.
Even if you have it just a
mediocre Dick. Right? Okay.
Your Dick is bigger than it's fucking
legs. I mean that's a tiny little animal.
You're not going to stick your
Dick and it's, but that's true.
What if you're like an Asian
guy? Honestly, hey on Daria.
I don't know if that's true or not true
cause I don't go around looking at dicks.
No, there's another big
thing you can do. The,
there's a thing where they have
average penis size by by country. Yeah.
I think they didn't check me.
They didn't check you for how do we know
if they're getting accurate readings?
The sample size.
Do not believe any fucking statistics.
I don't believe them.
I gave up,
I believe in the Internet
only I fuckin Wikipedia.
It's an odd Wikipedia. Um, yeah,
so rocks theory is he's the only
guy who's funny, dirty prior.
His best fit would be mud
bone or the, the, the,
I think the Italian guys are the thing
that was on here. Any good jokes?
Look prior had a million bits that are
all amazing and epic and legendary and
they were great because he did
whatever he wanted to. Whether you,
if you want it to be cleaned as clean,
if you want it to be dirty, he was dirty.
I think the secret is be who you are.
There's the idea of clean or dirty. Well,
if you're talking about subject manner,
the idea of working clean is
ridiculous. Like what? What?
What is your life I haven't had
the lights have to do with you?
Life is taking a shit in. Life is eating
food. You life is getting into arguments.
Your life is having sex. Your life
is, your life is driving and traffic.
Your life is a bunch of
fucking things that go on.
And if you leave out the ones that
are weird or sexual, when you leave,
you're going to eliminate a
bunch of things. You can't talk.
I gotta say,
I'm not a big fan of poop jokes though,
as like a level of difficulty thing.
Let me tell you something. This
dude, I hear you, but a guy who's,
this weekend it was with,
it was a hunting guide,
told me a story about an old man
shitting his pants and his car,
and it was one of the funniest fucking
stories I have heard in months.
It was a hilarious story about this crazy
old man that he had there that was on
this a hunting trip and
was fucking missing.
Everything is shooting and everything
and swearing, and it was just crazy.
Crotchy old man. I'm not
saying Shit, his pants. I mean,
I'm not doing this story any justice, but
this dude told Cody, told me the story.
By the way,
a thank you to the,
to hone ranch or taking care of
me and Steve Rinella this weekend.
We had a great time.
If you in southern California and you've
ever thought about hunting and going
hunting with a guide, you've got
to go through all the requirements,
like getting your license and all
that stuff, but the, to hone ranch,
it's an hour outside of California
or an hour outside of La and
I've never seen a place like this.
It's fucking crazy.
W There's at least 50,000 pigs on
this ranch. We were wild pig hunting.
Pigs are everywhere. Fucking
monster, 400 pound bores. We saw elk,
they have Colorado Rocky mountain elk
there an hour and a half from La Dude,
an hour and a half from La. I'll show you
the pictures of the place. It's insane.
You would never believe that
this is in southern California.
I mean it's like essentially closer then
to us than San Diego is and it's the
fucking wilderness.
We saw dozens of coyotes.
We saw at least 50 deer. We saw at
least a hundred pigs wandering around.
Homeless Guy, right? No,
no, no, no homeless guys.
They don't allow you to do that anymore.
In the 70s.
They pass regulations protecting the
homeless from hunters. But it's a, if,
if you want to go on a guided hunt and
if you want to be close to cal southern
California,
you can't do better to hone ranch,
tee Jio and ranch fucking great place.
And uh,
they took care of me and Steve Rinella
big time was really, really fun.
You stay on the ground. So yeah,
they have, they have a cabin there.
You stay at the lodge. They have
TV. You Watch TV, food, you know,
and it's a nice little place. Would
you kill, kill the big fat pig?
I'll show you a picture of Oculus
wild pig. What kind of gun? Uh,
I used a 300 wind mag.
It's a rifle. That's a pig.
That's me. No one wants to see it
clean. It looks like a little, uh, yeah.
[inaudible] was a great example. I totally
agree. I, it's not a perfect theory.
He's saying like top 10 of all time,
the People's best bits are clean.
Whatever nonsense this is,
I,
I just think whenever you say this
is always that in stand up comedy,
it's very hard to do that
because we'll rock and sign.
Fuck you say no one tan
is funny and no one,
no one in good shape.
It's funny.
I've heard that one before and that
one made me insecure when I was first
starting. I used to wear baggy clothes
to hide my fucking sexy. Oh fuck.
I didn't, you know, it looked like a
jock. I look like a Douche bag. I know it,
but that's what I looked like, man,
I can't do anything about that.
Don't be all fucking generalizing.
Well,
that's how I feel sometimes
where it's like, yes, sorry.
I have five brothers. I'm,
I'm fucking, I'm jockey. Yeah.
My favorite example of you can't tell
somebody what's funny and what's not.
You can't is Mitch Hedberg,
who was one of my favorite all
time comedians and squeaky clean.
There's just never barely ever talked
about sex. If I can remember, I mean,
might've had one or two jokes here or
there, but mostly it was really hilarious,
silly observations.
That was his whole act and in a weird,
weird way that nobody would ever t tell
you you should do no one who would ever
teach her how to do it. Oh yeah. The
best comics are like, that's what I said.
The top 10 comics at the top
hundred comics haven't gone
to a comedy class. Yeah.
The, I once said, the bottom hundred
may have, but you know what, man,
you know you could be a great comic
one day and go to a comedy class.
It doesn't disclude you from, is that
a word? Thanks. Click word. Yeah.
Disclude that I make that up. I think
that's better. I think that's valid.
The next clue. Fuck. Then it's settled.
You know? Disclude sounds better.
It seems like a good word.
See you put that in the urban dictionary
along with Shiela bouffed.
That's the Newman. Sia.
Shiela. Charlotte bouffed.
Yeah. What's that?
You got in a bar fight again at the same
bar that he got in a fight like last
year. Well, he's a rough, tough guy.
He's a rough and tumble character.
You know when you're around him,
he's, he's kind of a pirate.
He's ready to ready to steal your
material and he's ready to punch you.
I think that keeps his bipolar,
by the way.
I'm sure there's something really
wrong with him. He's an actor. Yeah.
There's this, 90% of them
are broken, broken people.
There's something wrong with them. Of
course. Here it's fucking crazy. The Guy,
we saw the psychopath thing, the comics
are all psychopaths. Yeah. Oh, for sure.
Yeah.
Joey Dee is a hundred percent psychopath.
That's why he's the funniest guy on
earth. Yeah. I have no problem going like,
yeah, of course you can't. Our
brains are scrambled. Yeah,
but it doesn't mean you're
going to act on those impulses
is you know people have wild and impulses
all the time that you don't act on it.
Just your brain thinks in weird
ways and you can sort of a use that,
that valve and turn that
valve on the comedy.
I also think we want to be liked too
much to murder somebody. That's not true.
Yeah. After you get over that,
after the show, a bunch of,
you don't need that many people like you.
I get it,
but I'm saying like if you kill somebody,
you know it's going to,
your numbers are going to drop
on the road while you will.
If you kill somebody for your free.
Sure. Excluding them forever for being a,
from being from, yeah, from killing
onto your website can be a fan.
They're not going to join your mailing
list. I'm on following you on Twitter.
Oh my God. When I beat this guy to death,
he's never coming back to my Twitter.
Yeah. Yeah. Good point. Thank you.
I know how you think you think ahead.
I would never have a number of things
that I think it was think ahead.
You plan a couple of stature,
a couple of steps ahead. Yeah.
You've got to plan for the future when
it comes to beat someone to death. Yeah,
I'm fucking, you don't have that
Irish fucking vengeance thing,
huh?
No,
I,
well if I did when I was young
I eliminated it at all with
thinking and you know,
do you won't treat it as I've argued.
Do you argue with people in your head?
I don't allow myself to do an immune
that anymore. I used to do that.
I used to do that when I was a young
man. I used to, if I was a young man,
I got an argument.
Someone I would relive that argument like
everyday for like 10 minutes for like
a year. Maybe I'll come back to it a
year later. Yeah. It's fucking guy.
I should have told that fucker.
Well fuck you mister.
You have to like go through your notes.
Like what was I going to say to him?
Oh yeah. I was going to say that
I just talk about this on stage.
This is totally true. When I was a,
I guess I was like 26,
I live,
I was living in Encino and I rented this
house and it had an orange tree in the
front yard and I didn't pay my bills.
It's very irresponsible.
So this guy came over,
uh,
I had turned the power back on and the
guy came over to turn the power on and it
seemed like a nice guy. I said, hey
man, uh, those oranges and delicious,
if you want one, go grab one.
And he goes, okay, thanks.
So the guy took nine fucking orange
and I sat there watching them like this
motherfucker, he's taken more
orange. I can't believe this shit.
And to this day, man, I have to fight
off the urge. No, no, no, no, no.
It's not that story like
three times. It, it's real.
Like I was an asshole for to this day
I'll be in my car and I'm driving down the
street and I'll just go nine
fucking orange is really,
that was 1993 did I tell you the
story that the alone told me?
But I tell it on this podcast,
no. Shit. Like this never happens.
Me
Heaven one time flew to,
we're going to fight to a Mayweather
fight and we get on the plane and fucking
Stallone is waiting
for us. I'm proud of, come on in. Hello.
All right. I guess we're going
to a fight with Stallone.
It's great thing about Stallone. He
knows what his good stories, ours. He,
you know what I mean? He like knows
what people want to hear about.
They want to hear about rocky.
They want to hear about fucking,
they want to hear it.
So he's talking about he was
directing the movie staying alive. Oh,
uh, yeah, I remember that. Yeah, he
was, and it was a Travolta movie that,
that Frank Stallone sang on the
soundtrack. That is correct. Um,
so yes.
So Stallone said that he,
he goes, he goes, so I,
I called John Up to the house for meeting
about that song, play that song. Why the
stories? He goes alone, this is the end,
I think it's called. This is
the end. And he staying alive.
He goes, he goes. So John came up and
he goes, John's got a real food issue.
People don't know that. And he
goes, he goes, John comes up,
we're sitting at the
table. And he goes, now,
my wife had made some
homemade fudge that day.
So we sit at the table,
my wife puts out some fudge Travolta
proceeds to eat the entire plate of food.
This fucking guy over,
man. He goes, he goes,
which first of all,
his fucking route,
which is fucking made me laugh my
head off. And that was like that.
He hasn't forgotten that he, that's
his orange story is that, is that, um,
is that it was fucking rude. That's still
owned or that a turmoil. Tate, all of us.
Well, he's hanging on to some shit
from the early eighties right?
One was staying alive.
That was the 82.
Remember when he's walking
down the streets in New
York City with a fucking fur
coat on and it got bumps into him.
Travolta bumps it on like so long.
You really remember this movie.
It's the wrong song. Is that
it? Yeah. What does it say?
It's called far from over.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. This is a great
fucking song. Okay. Change. Yeah.
This is
the loans,
the loans brother.
This fucking song was
the shit back in the day.
I wish I knew how to dance song.
I'm downloading this.
I'm even fucking around and then say,
I forgot about this.
I wish I knew how to dance back then.
I want it to be a part of this world.
I wanted it to be the impressive guy on
the dance floor spinning around and in a
perfect position. It's still, oh,
he said that they were shooting
flashdance next door and he's like,
and we knew that that was going to
be the one John Travolta met a single
handedly,
made more men gay just from this music
and from singing and dancing and getting
people to dance. He probably purse. That
was probably his total overall goal,
which is to say nothing of his bath house
work. Just ours, the Shaw's power work,
but just to be able to dance so good
and make dancing, fucking dancing.
It's not the Fred Astaire days. This is
a new era of manliness. We get frank.
You were, did you ever go to like a
disco or, yeah, I did that. Of course.
So how else do you want to get laid?
We want to just stand around with a sign.
Please fuck me.
And you fucking take it out there.
Neil Brandon out there and you did it,
dude.
I had Kava Ricci pants tight on the top
and they ballooned out like Mc Hammer.
PCO owes all that shit and I went on
stage with those ones. It was a disaster.
Look at him, but he made dancing
a manly thing that was attractive.
This is one of the gangs things you
could see a man do ever look at that.
Back that up for two seconds that I want
to show you what those guys are getting
a hand job. You know what they're
doing. Know they're doing.
They're pretending they're near a
million dicks here. This shit you,
you suck at Youtube. Now
this youtube sucks. Does it?
Well, this is the, uh,
standard compilation that you had
to have in those old school movies.
You to have this series of scenes. We
could see him failing, failing, failing,
and then practicing really
hard and it's dancing. See,
he's waiting tables, but
when it gets out there, boom,
fuck doesn't waiver me. I use a phone.
I need the phone and everybody, what is
fucker is crazy. God Damn Mind.
Yes. You're going to get to be gay.
Come dance. Yes, I can dance. Fuck.
Look at this though. This movement.
Look at that thing with the toes.
Whenever you point your toes like that,
you're begging for decker literal. Yeah,
man. You're pointing your toes. A
cry for help. We were begging for it.
It's on the wrong with Pega for deck.
Don't get me wrong.
Nothing wrong with being gay. To,
to volt is a bad motherfucker.
Turn turned off for a drug off. Those
are decks. That's a hundred deck.
That is just gimme. Dik Dik Dik. Dik. Dik.
Dik Dik she'll be moving
your fist towards your face.
He trying to hit yourself in the face.
It's clearly not an outward move where
the retraction is just bringing it back
to position. No, they're
pulling down. That's pulling
Dick's into your mouth. Yeah,
I told him, look, I totally like I saw
it. I saw it. Nothing wrong with that.
That's another testament to the,
to the gays are having a blessed yes,
they're having more fun for sure
George Michael and of having a blast.
You know what? The gains are not having
fun. The ones who fuck up and adopt kids,
they start thinking I'm going to be like
a family. We're going to get to that.
We're going to get married.
We got adopt kids.
And I'm like what does that a lot of
fucking work wise they had the key,
they were winning the race and nobody
had the baby out of their body.
Neither one of them.
So they're both standing there
with this little motherfucker.
It's causing all sorts of problems. Damn,
I fucked up the whole big gay party.
Is this another gate? What are you doing
here? Okay. Cause she's, she's acting,
she's talking about her baby.
Like you know how you were
just saying the Dixon mouth.
This is a news reporter saying how she
used to take her a electric toothbrush
and to help her kids gums, but she did
it on air and it just like completely
keep the music playing.
Look at her, look at it. That's to Dixie.
She's docking Dick's and then
she's tasting them. Yum. Yum,
yum, yum, yum, yum. Yum. Oh,
I'm going to sneeze on your Dick
as delicious.
Yeah.
It's funny that you're not supposed to
ever think of those people being sexual.
Like if she actually did do that and
start it with like, like code. Yeah.
I fucking believe this guy homeroom.
I think that's the fun,
one of the fun parts about having sex
with women is how different it is from
what they're normally like.
Cause you and I are eight or 10 seconds.
I can imagine you fucking within eight
seconds of right now someone wants to
fuck and he's really close to me.
I know what you're doing.
Whereas in girls got fucking
jewelry on and her decorum.
I see what you're in like.
And then the difference between like
a girl in real life and a girl getting
fucked or fucking is so fast and
it's so awesome and so exciting.
You mean it really talking dirty and get
her fucking sweating and they fucking
legs or splits the best picture near
Brennan fucking now I can't help it.
You're so clever. I see what
you've done, both of you together.
Should she get together and try
and find my demise man's videos.
One got together. He's got a heck of a
video. You should really check out Joe.
I'm going to get you to think about a guy
sucking a guy's Dick and I'm gonna get
you to watch it. And then you're like,
I want you to think about me having sex,
so I see what you both have
done. How dare you? How dare you.
Some comic was telling me that
today when he'd go on the road,
him and his buddies who were
staying at the hotel together,
they knew that they were going to try
to bring girls back to the hotel room
afterward. Uh, and they wanted the
girls to not be wearing a lot of closer.
They would turn the heat
up as high as they can
in the hotel room. That's
weird. Is that how dumb girls
they'll get naked and next
thing I know we're fucking,
because you know how that goes.
When people get really hot and lethargic,
that's when they're the best. They want
it can't stop thinking about the fucking,
when you're about to dehydrate,
you're about to black blackout.
That's when you really want to throw
down. Yeah. Just bring a lot of water.
Give them water and they'll fuck you.
Are you add and on me right now literally
wanting to check out right there.
That's what I'm saying. Don't do
that. Put that fucking phone man.
You can donate it. The flow of
the conversation is interrupted.
If you let those fucks in your mind.
I thought you were. I felt like
the flow. I felt like you
were putting a dam up a damn.
I thought you were fucking
beavering conversation.
Don't want to think about you
fucking or I don't want this one.
Did walk through where the flow
was going. Joe, I got news for you.
That's where it was headed.
It was there already going there.
It was already there.
Brian's got videos of bears
making out for no reason
to own ranches. Bears too. They have
a fuck a little amount or killing? No,
he can't cannot them anymore.
Oh yeah, you can't actually,
you can't hunt with dogs.
Can't have them outline.
So they let the mountain lions live.
People are all fucking bleeding
heart about the mountain lions.
Like they wanted to keep the
mountain lion population up. Okay.
You sure? Like why? Like there's a lot of
them, you know, she'll be really careful.
Too many. Oh yeah, for sure.
100% no doubt about it.
There's definitely too many mountain
lions. There's too many mountain lions.
There's too many wolves
in America as well.
But a California has a real mountain
line issue cause mountain lion hunting is
not legal.
So they're allowed to just keep reading
and keep [inaudible] just slaughtering
deer like crazy. And also like
house pets too. Oh yeah, definitely.
House pets and occasionally the
jogger when it was, you know,
a person you fuck up, they'll catch a
person slipping every couple of years.
And Jackie,
especially a woman or a child,
my lines are God damn dangerous and
California has a large population of them
and you can eat them too,
by the way,
but they won't let you hunt them
because people are all like,
oh the majestic cat, but a beautiful
creek and they are cool as fuck to see.
But you can't let them get out of hand,
man.
You can't with the populations get
out of hand. That is real shit.
This is all chitter chatter and
it's all just nice and cool to talk.
And we're sitting in this air conditioned
room in the valley and we know we have
a computer in front of us. When you
are out there, if you are in the woods,
well you shouldn't be in the woods.
That's their world. The fuck it is.
This whole plan. It's our world. Okay.
And anywhere where people
live human to human beings,
this is teen people, my
friend, we own this planet.
It doesn't mean you should
be a con killed dolphins.
But what I'm saying is if you're walking
through the woods, beautiful woods,
and you'd like to enjoy it,
but a mountain lion wants to eat you,
that mountain line can go fuck itself.
That's what I think.
I think we should kill a certain
amount of them and make sure that their
populations are in the point
of killing deer. Right?
It's like you can kill deer because
there's so fucking many of them.
Do your pose a threat only in the sense
that they carry diseases like you can
get, um, a lot of deer ticks and Lyme
disease, Lyme disease, you can get that.
People get that and it's absolutely
devastating. But that's sort of like,
that's not their fault. And they also
carry the risk of auto accidents.
A huge issue in places
that have like farmland,
like they're killing deers
all the time in those places.
And you're talking about massive
damage to your car and you could die.
Like many people have died hitting a deer.
The deer goes through the windshield.
You get gored with its antlers,
you get kicked to death. Yeah,
100% that has absolutely happened.
But the mountain line thing is they'll
hunt you. I mean they really will.
If you're hiking and you're
alone and you have a lamp,
you twisted your ankle and you don't have
a gun and you're wanting this mountain,
mine sees you limping and it's hungry.
Especially if it's an old cat.
It really can't catch dear
anymore. You're fucked. All right.
And I don't think that
that should be the case.
I heard that that's how they catch.
You can't kill one in self defense.
You might be able to get away with
it if you kill it and self defense.
But my point is that malicious,
the population be should
be kept under control.
They have a good census of how
many animals exist and the,
the numbers are very high
and they can hunt them.
So the numbers are going
to continue to go up.
And once something becomes illegal,
which I believe it became in 91 they
made mountain lion hunting and legal,
it's very difficult to turn that
around and do it the other way.
But in most states that
have mountain lions,
they have mountain lion hunting and they
have a season on mountain lions and it
is just to keep their populations
healthy and in check and not make them
dangerous.
There's no concern about mountain lions
going extinct like anybody thinks there
is,
is totally missing the misunderstanding
what's going on or just completely
incorrect. They're there.
They're dangerous, man. Where's
this one? Sun Valley? Yeah.
Okay. How big are they? Well,
they can get to be 150 pounds.
I've seen too in my life and they were
both maybe like 60 the first one was
probably like 60 pounds and the
second one got your dog or something.
That was about 60 pounds.
It wasn't a big cat. Yeah.
Video killed this dog or is that
supposedly killed this dog? Of course.
Don't they do a thing where they lower
the dogs in? No, that's files. Coyotes.
I lie. I got to say I respect the
coyotes for that. They're gangster. Yeah,
they're very clever. Those
sneaky fell act, they'll,
they'll act like they let the dog into
their pack and then they just eventually
get like, oh no, we're going
to eat. We tricked you.
Well what they do is one get one coyote
will show itself and bark or make noises
and try to get the dog to chase it.
And then if the dog chases it,
it'll chase it into an ambush and the
other counts, and that's super common.
They also like a female coyote that's in,
in heat.
She'll show herself in that for the same
reason to get males because they know
that male dogs will come after them
and they just set them up. Lira trap.
There was a guy who
worked at my pet store,
I think I've told this story before
on the podcast, but he, uh, had a dog,
he was working at the
veterinarian's assistant,
have dog come in really big pit
Polak hundred 20 pound pit bull,
one of those crazy ones that they breed,
like land of the giants.
You ever heard of that breeding company?
The pip pit bulls traditionally
used to be about 35 pounds.
Then they started making them bigger,
especially for like boar hunting.
Like I used to have a boar hunting dog.
He's about 90 pounds is a big pit bull.
This one was way bigger than that. It's
120 pound dog. Okay. And it's covering,
it looks like a pit bull.
It's just huge to giant monster.
What are they breed it with? Well they
just breed them for size. They take,
it's still pit balls, but they just take,
some of them don't. Some of them breed,
they'd be, they create what they
call a Bam dog, which is a breed,
a pit bull with a mastiff and
try to get a larger pit bull.
I actually have one of those now. There's
the sweetest dogs in the world. Yeah, no,
I have a pit bull. He's the
best. But I mean this one's not,
I mean he has no dog aggression. He's
math massive and they bred it. The guy a,
it's called a regency mastiff. And
what it is is the guy, his dad,
curly was actually on fear
factor and his dad was a,
they put people in the suits and they
would sic the dog out on the dog,
would grab him, boom.
Slammed to the ground.
I think there's a video of
curly from fearful. That was
early fear factor, right?
No,
don't know the first episode ever.
We use Belgian malinois and they're
really small dogs. They're, you know,
there may be like 60 pounds impressed
that. I know my fear factor episodes.
Do you know it probably better than
me. I was stoned the whole time. Yeah.
But this, um, the early days,
the Belgium al wants the
problem is the really big guys.
Like we had my friend Pete,
Pete, the cop, and Chicago,
maybe I'll see you this weekend.
Pete, uh, peed, uh, the,
the dog bit him and he just fucking
ran with that dog. He's like, bitch,
he likes dogs only like 60
pounds. But I, in my head,
I feel like I could beat him six pounds,
that Doug will eat your asshole.
But if you're in one of those big suits,
like here, you can see it. See, this is a,
this is a Belgian malinois stow.
These are the smaller dogs.
And it took this young girl down,
but this girl was, you know,
probably about 110 pounds at the most.
But my friend Pete is about,
he's back there with the dark hair,
big studly copies of boxer and yeah,
he's about to 20 solid all American male
and that dog bit a hold of him and he
just ran with it. Here's my buddy
Pete. Um, but that's not the dog look,
look up curly curly is,
uh,
my dog's name is Johnny Cash and
curlies Johnny Cash, his dad.
Best dog I've ever had. That wasn't
the same episode though, right? No,
totally different episodes. But this
dog is the best dog I've ever had.
He's so sweet.
He's just sweet and smart and he's just
cool and chilled out and it's the best.
Yeah, he's awesome. But anyway, this
dog was about Johnny side. My dog,
Johnny is about a buck 40. This dog
was close, like a buck 20 comes back,
a pit bull covered and
cuts his fucking stay.
Thousand stitches literally all
over his body. And they're like,
what happened to your dog? He's like, I
don't know. I came home, eat something at,
obviously attacked him.
You know,
they thought it was a cat
or something like that. They
follow a blood trail. Okay.
From where this fucking dog,
I mean,
severe cuts all over this dog's body go
up into the hills where they find nine
dead coyotes. Wow. Looked like a scene
from fucking saving private Ryan.
Look at this, uh, like, here's
a, that's a different dog.
But that's also a big strong dog. That's
a, that's an American bulldog that, uh,
Joe, the guy who was the
trainer, um, also had,
but curly was this mother fucker,
this giant black mastiff.
Anyway, this, uh, this guy, they found
what happened with those dogs was that,
you know,
this group of coyotes had been doing
that on a consistent basis and there's
several dogs in the neighborhood had
gotten killed and it just set the trap for
the wrong dog. So awesome. This
dog slaughtered nine coyotes.
He said it was just insane.
Like their guts are hanging out,
their next ripped open
and this dog was apparently,
you know,
came back and that goes through
your action movie philosophy,
which is the coyotes weren't waiting
for him to take on one dog at a time.
Cause in your head you go, he just
took on one coyote to time. No, no,
they all attacked and he beat all of
them. Yeah, he killed nine coyotes.
That's what, and he's a, he's a domestic
dog and he's a pet. He's there to mass.
And then do you ever see when your dog
gets like, Oh yeah, he's an animal.
He, they're nice. Every
once in a while my Pipa,
we'll do something that's like at the
dog park, he's unbelievably sweet.
But a couple of times he's just been like,
by the way,
I'm a pitbull and I'll just
fucking snap at somebody.
And not somebody but another dog. It's
the, I'm proud of that as well. Yeah.
You gotta be careful with
those things. Yeah. I,
if I explained to him that pitbulls killed
people, he'd curl, he'd be confused.
That's curly of you. So
show him, hit somebody.
It's super impressive. Oh, this
is a two people we, that's right.
We use two people together
cause curly curly was so strong.
It was one person was too ridiculous.
He was fucking people up.
It's just such a horrible thing because
even though the dogs like you wearing a
big suit, your boot, the guy
was wearing a big giant suit.
So it's like the dog
couldn't rip it apart.
It's still clamping down on your
filling pressure, right? Yeah.
It's like bone breaking pressure.
It's a giant animal and
not a coyote's best friend.
But that dog is like,
it's as big and tough as that dog is.
It's not like 120 pound pit bull, 2100
120 pound pit bull would kill that dog.
It's a different animal. A pit bull
is a completely different species.
The difference between what it
can do and what it can tolerate.
So that's a smaller dog.
That's like a shepherd.
Probably the difference between what it,
how it tolerate and it's killed drive.
Like that's a perfect example.
That dog of selective breeding pitbulls
thousands of years of only taking dogs
that will ignore pain,
fight to the death and never back down
and keep it and use only those genetics
and get rid of the ones that don't share
those genetics in such a cruel way.
They would kill dogs, they would quit
and fights. They would kill them.
They would take them out and kill them.
And that was the whole deal
with a fuckhead. The uh,
the football. Yeah. Yeah.
Michael Vick is that he was
murdering dogs that quit. Yeah.
Which is a longstanding
tradition. Yeah. It's terrible.
I'm sure it was only made
illegal 50 years ago.
I don't know when it was made
illegal. There's curly. Well,
this dog grabs my dog's
unbelievably sweet.
When someone knocks at the door
or tries to just jiggled it,
he barks and goes to the door,
but his tail wags.
So my worry is I wonder if he
would know when I'm in danger.
Oh yeah. He would know for
sure. They would smell it.
They know what a dog senses
about a situation is so
much different than what we
sense because they smell, especially
with live organisms, you know,
we would understand danger like physical
objects, cars and things coming at you.
The dog wouldn't, but dog smell
fear. They smell emotions. They'll,
they'll smell this comfort. They'll,
they'll smell things on you.
You'd give away pheromones and
if you were like in terrifying,
a terrifying situation and someone was
violently going after the dog would smell
intention like would literally
smell the intent of the attacker.
That's why dogs don't like certain people.
When you got a creepy fuck
over your house and your dog
or my dog only barks at
homeless people of all races,
he'll bark at homeless people and
drunk people that are walking weird.
It's the,
I'm so,
I fucking love him for it because it is
people that I'm not that I'm creeped out
by anyway. They're very, very soon
our dogs, pit bulls, very smart dogs. But
look, I mean you think about a dog smell.
Someone like you or someone like Brian
or anybody, they smelled fairly normal.
You know, the varying a little bit,
then all of sudden you come around.
This guy wasn't Washington six years.
Yeah. He's covered his own pitch.
You're like, Whoa, for a dog, you
know, bad must smell. It must be like
Jesus fucking Rah, Rah Rah. Yeah.
Why don't you do it in my face?
Like you're assaulting my notes,
your stinky piss soaked pants.
I saw homeless woman last night
at the Highland, that church,
that big church on Highland. Uh, and
uh, and yeah, if Franklin Franklin,
uh,
this woman just co it was at a stop light,
she just gets up and she was
like laying down. She stands up,
pulls down her pants into shits right in
front of all of us waiting in line and
people started honking the horn and
she was like flipping everybody off and
stuff. Yeah, I do. I judge
that, but I would shit if I
was in the woods, but for her,
that's the woods middle. This sidewalk.
She doesn't have a home, sir. Yeah.
Where did you want to go?
Where you want it to go?
You want to go to the Jack in the
box? Your toilet to Starbucks? Yeah.
It's better than going to a
restaurant. I'm man. Yeah.
Imagine if she walked out of
the, the bisexual. What is the,
what's coed coed bathroom at
Starbucks. You go in after her. Yeah.
Fucking a fucking cloud of fleas
and it's not just the shit.
It's the everything.
It's like a flow thing and the end,
the air is heavier. The feet. It's
like the God damn post office.
[inaudible] cheese [inaudible]
taint cheese on the lid.
You can't just wash that off with paper
towels and some lukewarm water from the
sink. You got to hover over it. If you'd
take a shit two year old yeast infection,
I don't take shit.
Please. Absolutely fine.
I've been taken a shit in public.
I think it lifetime under five.
I did one yesterday. Don't be scared if
you have to take a shit and take a shit.
That's what a bathrooms for. I don't
care. I don't care if I'm here. My farts,
I don't care if you hear the plop
and splash. There's bathrooms. Shit.
I got a whole, you know I have a day
and we talked about in that for you.
I got one of those Japanese toilets.
Warms your asshole with a hairdryer. Yeah,
I got it. The tone. I toil. I drink a lot
of Kale shakes, man. You can't just, yeah
judge when your shits are coming.
If you're drinking Kale shakes,
you've got to accept the fact
you're gonna shit six times a day.
So a lot of times I'm not home.
Okay, so I got to shit. I also
would like to take a 1520 minute,
those are nine down.
Especially if you have a bad diet
and you go slowly push out poop.
No,
it all comes out.
I don't need to be there and say
it was you buddy pass and no,
get the fuck outta here.
Rogan and Mike Shit is fine.
It's a little defensive. Hey,
who the fuck are you? Yo,
you better tell your friends.
Nursing friendly person
talking about poop.
Someone said he doesn't want to look like
a little shit story a little earlier,
like a shit story.
But I do like,
I know I do like talking about taking
long shifts. I do like have a day store.
It seems different. I'm also not trying,
I don't like shit stories on stage.
Big Daddy Kane was on our podcast last
night and told a story where he was
trying to pee on a girl and
ended up shitting on himself.
So great story. So it is a very
great story and a, that'll be
Jim Breuer has a story about his,
uh,
his dad shitting himself that bill burst
says when the funniest bits he's ever
seen in his life. It's
like a 10 minute. Yeah.
And it's like a destruction
bit and then he closes with it.
I guess it's supposed to be unbelievable.
It's a shed story. So how dare you.
Yes. That's not impossible. Brian
closes with this shit. Right?
A lot of shit stories going around. Neil
Brennan, Fan of Shit Joke. I'm just not,
not into it. Just not into it.
Okay. It's all right. You know,
I understand you have
to defend your position.
You'll reconsider after this is over.
You go back and you know you want
to drive home. Hey, pull over.
I think Jill might've been right. Shit
stories. What's bad and what's good?
What's bad. But I'm saying
like as a, you know, onstage,
I opened with one off side just hey,
you're a shitty dude. What can you say?
Ooh.
Put that anywhere
near what the shit jokes.
What I tell Ya.
Yeah, yeah. No, no subject
is off limits. It's just,
you just have to have something to say
about that subject so it has to be legit.
What do you do it by the ass hair? What
do I do personally? I just deal with it.
You don't whack. I shaved my
balls where I leave my ass alone.
It's probably not a good strategy
as far as like cleanliness.
I had a friend who was shaved his ass
and I was like, why do you do that?
And he's like, dude, I got tired of having
shit in my pants all the time. He goes,
if you have a hairy ass and you
smell it smeared with toilet paper,
what do you think is going on
there? Yeah. I've always said,
it's like peanut butter
from a shag carpet. You're
rubbing it in your ash hairs.
He's like, I got a hairy ass.
It's just not cleanliness,
not cleanline. So he goes,
I started shaving my ass and now it's
beautiful. He knows now I wipe it.
Then I baby wipe it and boom.
I have a clean ass all the time.
My underwear smells better.
I don't itch as much better.
He got married like eyelashes though.
It's supposed to protect it.
So like spiders and
protected from spiders.
Good point.
I lashes fill out this questionnaire
to apply for your doctor examination.
Hmm. What are eyelashes for? To protect
you from spider fighters. Next question.
Don't insult my intelligence.
I'm going to med school. Sure.
Well we have just have a few questions,
but human body anatomy and what you know
and she is and what are the actions for,
what's the hair growing out of your
ear for a keep you from getting vd?
It is. You're right though. It is for
protection. Yeah, it's from dust, right?
And little particles keeps from what?
You've got. Hair covering your brain,
covering your mouth, covering your Dick
and ass. You know, something real weird.
Your thickest hair and your chest.
Technically he knows I'm really weird.
Even when it's really cold out,
your eyes don't get cold,
your eyeballs don't get cold. It's really
strange. Like we were in Wisconsin,
it was like fucking zero degrees outside
and the wind was whipping around.
It was really cold, really
cold, but I was like,
isn't it weird that my eyes aren't cold?
And then the guys I was with were like,
yeah, my eyes aren't cold
either. That is weird.
Everything else is fucking freezing.
Your toes are inside boots,
insulated boots and we'll and
your fucking feet are numb.
You remember that from Columbus? Those
fingers freezing. But your eyes we, yeah.
Why won't your ice freeze? I don't
know. The West is also, that's like,
that's a stone thought hall of fame
that goes like that and the nominees are,
and the inductees this year are,
why don't your know your eyes
hold Joe Rogan. Thank you.
Thank you very much. Thank you
very much. I appreciate it. Yeah,
I got high time stoner of the
year award. They do. Really? Yeah.
I'm supposed to like figure
out if I can go to some,
I'm not supposed to say that, but I'm
supposed to say that. Whoops. Whoops.
I got it. Either way. Have you not
one before times, uh, corruption.
Clearly the man, I don't know. You
know, I think, uh, it's ridiculous.
Like I don't even want it. There's, Ooh,
there's an answer. I mean, I want it,
but I'm not saying it's a bad thing. What
I'm saying is that, uh, you know, saint,
anybody's the best stoner
fucking ridiculous.
It's just the most famous stoner too.
I think it's the,
the good thing is,
is to celebrate that there's a lot of
people that enjoy marijuana and now that
it's finally slowly starting
to actually get legal,
it's good to see people that enjoy it
and are not spiraling out of control of
your life. I got to say, I happy,
I like the shit in Colorado.
You know about that bank stuff. Yes.
I think that's really fucking stupid.
It is stupid. It's just stupid. It's
evil. It's evil and it's all it.
It's like what it is for
people who don't know,
basically these dispensary's are
making a ton of cash mans yeah.
They're making something
like one dispensary.
I'll have 400 grand for the week or
something more for the week. Small one.
$1 million the first day.
First Day. Yeah. Uh, so,
but the problem is banks will not accept
the account that vape banks will not
accept money that's been
made on selling drugs.
So basically they have to
exchange them into money
orders and shit like that.
Unless those drugs are oxycontin.
PROZAC.
Lithium. Yeah. Yeah.
Uh, so yeah, so the,
it's so like these people who want to
Spencer's or having to switch cars and
like be on the lookout because they
opened a weed store, which is just stupid.
It's like you can't, you kind of can't
legalize it. And they'd be like, Nah.
Well what they're doing is trying to
hold back this inevitable tide. Yeah.
The inevitable tide of legalization people
fed up, man, I'm a fucking grown man.
I don't want another grown man telling
me I can't smoke pot. It's too late.
All right.
It's 2000 and God damn 14 it's not
going to ruin your life no matter what
fucking Nancy grace tells you.
It's not going to ruin your life no
matter what any of these knuckleheads tell
you it is not what's wrong. If
there's issues, if you have issues,
I mean psychologically, what does
this that your playing and Brian,
the Nancy versus Nancy where
she contradicts herself
though about marijuana and
we're, you know in the past
with Zimmerman though because
she ain't hear you.
Taffy. I mean people on
no the good do it from the beginning
because otherwise it's not going to make
any sense.
I think she was supporting Trayvon Martin
not being violent because he's right.
Oh Wow.
An evidence that Trayvon Martin did have
marijuana in his system at the time he
died. What difference, if any,
does that make out to you? Taffy?
I mean, people on pot that shoot each
other, the right stab each other.
I've strangling each other,
drive under the influence.
Isn't it true that when you smoke pot,
you just want to lay on the sofa and
eight? I mean, you do know it's addictive.
Highly addictive, right? I mean,
the common connotation
part goes with lethargy,
with uh,
the munchies with wanting to eat,
which looks like Angela
Lansbury about kill families,
wipe out a whole family
system.
To me it means that he is less likely to
pick a fight with somebody you've never
met. Nick Diaz. She ended
up losing her job. Oh,
wrecked her car, couldn't make
the house payments on our house.
This is a real problem. She's Indian.
She's a demon sent from Satan to ruin our,
our fucking lives and spreading nonsense.
That's hilarious.
Just the fact that she communicates,
it's such a sloppy way. That's the,
that's how she organizes her thoughts
and distributes them on hello.
It's all terror. Oh,
she's in constant terror.
It's full talk. It's talk for fools, which
she was doing was just saying, you know,
it was all,
you know,
flavoring the reality with their
own stupid ideas. It's just gross.
It's nonsense. You know, she couldn't fit.
She couldn't make up her mind what it is.
Does Pot make you violent?
Does it make you lazy?
Does it ruin lives?
Does it make you lethargic and eat
chips? Which one is it? You know,
it's, SNL had a very funny skit this past
weekend. That's hardly possible. Yeah,
it's 2014. No, no, no. It was
Drake did a fucking cat Williams.
He did a cat Williams impression.
That was fucking hilarious,
Brian. Okay. Uh, it's to
take a, we'll take a minute,
we'll just load it up and pause it so that
we have it's spooled up. But uh, yeah,
I'd say it's time man.
And there's nothing to do with like
you don't want it what it has to do,
even if I didn't smoke weed.
Okay.
What it has to do with his grown adults
telling you what to do. That's stupid.
How do you find,
have you driven drunk and driven stone?
I don't drive drunk. Have you and your
life? I have, when I was really young,
I maybe did it a couple of times and I
realized how fucking dumb it was and I
got away with it, but I
wasn't like sloppy, hammered.
Like I could walk straight and I
certainly was under the influence though.
And I got away with it and I realize like
that is a dangerous thing that's easy
to do. It's easy to just leave a party
fucked up to leave a bar fucked up.
I don't, you know, when
I was in high school,
a good friend that I knew from high school
killed his friend in a drunk driving
accident. Nice kid in my neighborhood.
He said he was a nice guy.
I used to say hi to him all the time.
I saw him all the time and I ran into
him maybe six months after the accident
after, you know, he had, he's got all
this legal problems, his friend's dead,
his life is devastated. And I remember
that, look on that kid's face.
I was passing him,
I was coming home from work and he
was passing me on the street and I go,
what's up man? He goes,
hey, how are you doing?
And I could see the look in his face,
man.
He was just devastated six months later,
just devastated.
And I internalized that shit
and I absorbed that shit
and I said, God damn it.
Learned from that. Don't do that. Don't
do that. Yeah, that's a scary thing.
Don't drive trunk, man. But driving
high is a completely different thing.
It's not a good idea to drive high if
you don't know what being highest that's
for fuck shore. If you're not a
person who gets high all the time,
driving high is not a good idea. It's also
not a good idea. If you're on edibles,
edibles are way more powerful. Well,
there's a lot of visual shit with edibles,
right? Well, it's distortion. It's
distortion of w of the experience,
distortion of the experience of life.
And I think if if,
unless you're eating animals all the
time and you know what that distortion
feels like, it can be very
distracting. You know?
It's like you're not supposed to have
a fucking phone up to your head while
you're driving. You definitely shouldn't
be driving on pot cookies, you know?
But I know people who smoke weed and
drive all the time and they're fine.
I know. Also people though that
do Jujitsu high all the time.
They smoke.
I know people who podcast tank,
go ahead. Yeah, I'm not dude.
You can not believe it all you
want, Joe. I've seen it, man.
You have nonsense and propaganda
spouting out of your mouth.
Fuck man. Bullshit. But I think that,
you know, hold off for a second one that,
um, what was I saying? Drive high.
Look, some people can handle
it, some people can't. It's not,
it's not a black and white situation,
but what is black and white
is the influence of marijuana
is very different than
the influence of very,
very, very different.
We were talking about it before the show
that Obama had just recently said that
he thinks that pot is just as
safe as alcohol or out. No,
no more dangerous and alcohol,
whatever his statement was
and how that was a big deal.
It's a big deal to hear from a president
2014 regardless of what we know about
his past.
Yeah. It's still like he,
yeah, he did he smoke weed?
He said he used to buy coke
when he could afford it. Yeah.
That's my favorite fucking quote of all.
It's like I used to buy a little blow
when I could afford it by in a book by
Barack Obama.
It's so
great.
It's such a fucking ridiculous thing
that we're supposed to pretend that these
people who were running the
presidency or running whatever,
the being a senator when that they're
immune from all the things. Yeah,
us and we and our friends did
growing up like, oh, they didn't,
they never drank before.
They were 21 really?
What kind of weird square never gets a
hold of a little booze before they're 21
well, that's what Christopher
Hitchens one time said,
Bill and Hillary were fond of edibles.
He actually said he didn't because he
went to Oxford with them. He goes, no,
they didn't inhale.
They like to eat.
Ah, well that makes sense, man.
Completely different experience made
the man visionary fucked him up when he
came down to that one chick though.
That was ridiculous.
Yeah. That's what, when you
get, do you ever, I mean,
you've worked at places when you
have interns and you're like,
whenever I've interns, I'm like, I
wouldn't fuck any of these girls.
Just you can't, it's like,
well, you definitely can't
when you're the president,
right. When you can't, when you're
the executive producer, you can't,
when you're the right. I
didn't, I felt like I wouldn't,
I felt sometimes it's like
fucking an intern is like
executing a retarded person.
It's like it's just not a fair fight.
Okay. This is a bad example. Here's what,
here's why it's a bad example.
You're a young single guy who's
producing a television show.
He's the old married man.
I would rate US army.
The free world has ever known.
He's the commander in chief and
he's getting blown by interns.
That's like he's executing
some questionable judgment
and incredibly powerful
position. That's exactly my point.
Only blow jobs out your own.
That's exactly my point though. I
would, I wouldn't fucking intern to.
He would like, dude, it's a, it's an
abuse of power on my part. It's the one,
it's a wildly abuse of power in your part,
I would say spoils of war,
but you know, potato patato
nobody gets to be the president,
you know, like easily.
It's a fucking [inaudible].
You should get like one a month.
Like you literally should be.
It should be in the vous. Well, if they
had it rigged, right. The problem is
they all wrap on each other.
This is the real problem.
Like the FBI's ratting on the CIA,
the CIA's investigating this guy,
the senator,
and if they all just like chilled out,
they could have an endless supply of
Russian hookers come over to the White
House, has dignitaries and,
and have a great old time.
Secret Service had that
in Puerto Rico apparently.
Apparently they didn't want to pay.
That's, what was it? Puerto Rico was,
I think it was, yeah, I thought
it was South America, but
whatever, whatever it was.
The CIA got some prostitutes and
didn't want to give up the money,
which is fucking rude. Rude,
expecting ruby. Just like
eating the whole plant foot.
Yeah, it was a serious,
yeah. Yeah. Um, look man,
it's just sex once they have robot fucked
dolls that look exactly like people
like blade runner style.
I actually had that argument.
I asked the girl I was dating if
I fucked a robot who looked like,
who had like sort of like the stove,
which deny a robot,
like one of those like vodka of robot,
those vodka commercials where
it's like a sexy cyborg.
If I fucked that robot
or I fucked a robot that looked like the
terminator where it was more metallic,
the girl said she'd be way matter if
the robot had smooth skin than if it had
metallic skin.
Yeah, because it would be like, it's
not cheating. If you fuck a desk
that's fucking hilarious
about up the whole
and fight and she catches you fucking
the dash. She's just going to go,
what's wrong with you Neal Brennan?
Yeah.
Well that's awesome.
That elemental thing about
guys want to fuck when they go.
Like it's not just a whole I,
it's not just the whole
cause I'd fuck of warm melon.
I'd fuck it fucking hand one of those.
Whatever those things he used
to especially I haven't, yeah.
Fleshlight it's I want a woman.
I want to trick a woman.
You want to trick them well than
that's kind of what you're doing. Oh,
that's what it is. No, it's
not tricky. What it is,
you having sex with someone
who wants to have sex with you,
enjoying each other's body. What are
you? Fuck, there's a certain amount.
It's a trick. It's fucking, there's a
certain amount of seduction involved.
It's like Don Rawlings. She
used to say, let's listen.
Let's go out and trick bitches.
Wow. When you go to a bar,
it's a bit of Hocus pocus. Let's be
honest. You tell your best stories,
you tell your, you try it. You fucking,
you try to look as cute as possible.
You hold doors open. You
don't act like yourself. Well,
he's in the goal in life to get to a
point where you don't have to do that.
Isn't that the real goal in line?
I bet you were way nicer
to your girlfriend on your
fucking third date than you
are now.
This is, oh no, that's not true
at all. Me. No. Personally,
no. That's not true at all.
And not only that,
I would think that you're different.
You're dealing also with the difference
between you when you're 21 and you're
just getting into the came has missed a
white folks would say the game or when
you're 40, you know, and yeah,
you should be a man by now.
Oh yeah man.
I'm not saying you're not,
you see a man with my shit
or snow sovereign. Yeah.
Tea,
you should be a band that really is not
trying to impress a bunch of people and
is can live in his own skin and not
putting on a God damn show. You know,
putting clown shoes on
when you walk out the door.
All right, Jorge meals here.
You know, you're not doing it
that your men now, you
know, that's the difference.
That's why you shouldn't say trick girls.
Anyway.
I understand. Back in the
day it was a different way.
It's also just a funny term.
It is very funny.
And also it's a bitches.
Let's go to that con trick.
Fucking, it's also funny, you're coming
from a black guard. What isn't. Um,
but uh, yeah, but yeah,
like let's cut and trim.
I mean there is a certain amount of like,
you know chicanery involved for sure.
Well you know,
and also I when I always say be the man
you pretended to be where you're trying
to get laid,
be actually be that guy.
It might take a long time
and want to take some steps,
but work your way up to actually being
that guy and then you don't have to
pretend every time you get laid back is
actually who you are. I totally agree.
Be An actual admirable person and you'll
get some pussy Neal Brennan you do you
think? No. Yeah, I think you could fuck. I
think if you had to get thrown down. Yeah,
I do. All right. If I had a gas I
do. All right. I bet you put in work.
I bet you'd take it seriously. I bet
you're a very shamed of poor performances.
I bet you make an Ikea them.
Thank you.
And you don't want to
hold this fucking phone,
the start flashing every
time you get a goddamn text,
you one of those really needy fucks.
It has that setting on your phone where
the flash, the back flash goes like this.
Every time you have a tax flash flash.
I says,
I bet you have it every time someone
tweets you to you do. No, no. Come on man.
Those are Twitter notifications.
Joe, come on. Motha the comedy club.
That's so annoying cause you're on stage
and you think people are taking photos
of you. Cause I know a lot of
people have those flashes. Oh yeah.
And they keep them in the
desk. Yeah. On the table.
You know what I think that gets
integrated with a sexual performance.
Um, because a buddy of mine and I have
talked about this problem solving,
much of say cunnilingus is
you're solving a puzzle.
And I think that the smarter you are,
the better you would be a kind of legacy.
Maybe. But unless the girl is very
vocal, some girls are very vocal. Yeah.
But even the vocal ones,
it's like you have to,
you have to discern what's
is that you're gonna come,
you might come, stop, do it, go
to the right, go to the left.
It is very, it's a bit like a video, you
know, it's like a, it's a problem solving.
It's also very variable as far as what
people like and I absolutely guests or
blowjobs cause you ever get a blowjob
from a girl just locks a hold of the tip,
like a sucker fish and just
starts hammering the the
shaft and you're like, whoa,
whoa, whoa. Who likes
this? I know. Crazy shit.
Whoa. Slow it down. We're
getting crazy over here.
Talked about what, what makes it
a fantastic blowjob on the show?
Various, I dunno what you
like, but I bet it's weird.
I Bet I'm going to disagree with this,
but it involves trickery.
It involves cards and fucking Ravitz
coming out of a hat. What's this?
It's like that scene in diner
would make you work a had a bet.
See if we can get a girl to grab his dick
and the first date and he won because
he put his dick inside of boxes.
Oh yeah, you're taking a box. Yeah.
No, I think I have my things, but I,
I agree with you that I don't,
I don't, don't they? It's
not, don't fucking try to,
it's all good dude. As long as
I'm happy, she, it's very nice.
It's a beautiful thing. I'm glad
they do it. We have it way easier.
Like a girl comes.
It's
really not inconvenient. So
yeah, nothing Ha. It's invisible.
You don't have to swallow
a gallon of fucking,
and you also don't have to be judged on
one of the, you swallow or not like true.
She's was like woody.
Once it's out of my body,
I kind of don't care what she does.
Obviously the swallowing,
swallowing feels uh,
more complete.
She's filthier,
which is great.
It's all she like if she gets you,
she wants to ingest you.
That's very flattering. But
ultimately it's like, it's,
it's a little silly.
Okay. Incorrect.
Disagree. It's everything.
It's really important because
that's a girl that you want.
That's a girl who's willing to
do something absolutely crazy.
Suck your dick and swallow your comm and
then smile at you. That's what you want.
You want to grow who just
releases all over inhibition.
She's doing something wild savage.
But I think there's so many
of them do at this point.
So many of them do it at this point.
Now you're flip flop and you should be a
goddamn politician. What are you saying,
Neil Brennan to it at this point?
So many women do it.
I don't know. I'd never taken a blow
job statistic. I'm not like, excuse me,
Joe and my work. While you're stepping
out of a anthropology at the mall, can I,
can I ask you,
if you fill this out,
how do you feel when it got comes in
your mouth, you rushing to the bathroom?
Are you showing them a good time?
I find that 80% swell. Okay.
And Mike would try to
kiss you right after.
For me, I think what's nice
about girls is they give,
they know to leave a window,
don't kiss you for at least five minutes.
They're good about it.
What's fun about sex is two people
enjoying it and being loose and having,
you know, no inhibitions. When someone
has inhibitions, it's not fun, clumsy.
It fucks up the whole vibe of the thing.
And I'm not saying like asked to mouth
or something ridiculous and unhygienic
I'm just talking about regular stuff.
Something ridiculous and fantastic.
Like mouth says, you know, I have
no interest in. He Kolai some,
someone works for the pharmaceutical
companies. He's here to sell antibiotics.
Fair. Go asked him mouth. It's
fucking beautiful. Line of six people.
Hi, I'm from Eli Lilly. Yeah. He bought
them sit like that. A lot of it's,
I feel like a lot of guys sexual
stuff now. It's so much of,
it's just about power. You
are the weirdest motherfucker.
It's about trickery.
It's about, no, I really do. It's
standup. Doesn't joke about trickery.
It's just like, but it's about like
I want to come on your, I'll just,
it's like I'm going to do this
to you and you're going to,
it's like you're going to take it.
It's like, is she going to take it?
That's what I'm saying.
I don't, I'm not into it,
but I'm saying like there is a strain
of that. I'm really not into it.
I'm saying there's a strain of that.
I feel like red band,
you could be a part of that.
There is a strain of like of domination,
Shit like that.
Like there's a,
there's an element of conquering to male
sexuality that I don't know if there is
two female sexual actuality.
I think you're missing the being an actual
man part and that's why you feel this
way. I think it's devastating
to your self esteem.
So you don't feel like an actual man.
So you want to do trickery and domination.
You want, you're holding these
girls down and titty fucking him.
I see what you're saying or confusing.
A lot of different stories are,
and Stallone is there watching
your eyes are not cold.
Oh
No.
Play that. Um, um, thing. The dance
grace. Yeah, the Nancy grace thing. Sorry.
Lab thing.
What were his promise?
You Damn Right Nancy pimping.
Pimping baby.
Okay,
I understand you're in Denver,
Nancy. I am from Atlanta, but if we eat
is going to be legal up here in Colorado,
then consider me for
elbow rocky mountain high.
I mean
I'm not leaving until wildfires.
Burn up this whole state and make
all of Wyoming get the munchies.
You hear what I'm saying?
Wow.
I'm sorry Mr Cat will I find you very
charming. Oh, I never thought of Bio II.
Nancy, please. It is a mother
loving utopia up in here. Okay.
Just yesterday I saw 10 different
strangers make musical instruments out of
trash cans. They formed
a whole band. Nancy,
these mother lovers didn't know each
other three hours ago and now they're all
suddenly in colon. The
gang. It's a beautiful day.
So you're saying this is a utopia
and ever bins. All Dabi lamb power.
It's your sale days. Do you want
your cab robber to be Paul and Paul?
Do you want your babysitter
to be a Po Po Nancy?
I am Kat Williams.
I have not been around someone who
wasn't high on pot for the past 15 years.
Nancy, please don't trip on me baby. Okay.
Okay.
Hold on. This is not nearly as
good as you promoted it. No,
there's a line coming up.
It's very funny. Check might
Nancy,
somewhere out there is a man wearing
nothing but a snuggie and shower shoes and
he is only half as crazy as y'all as okay.
You good?
Is that the line that was like, wow,
okay. It's a good impression though,
is a very good impression. But it sucks
here. And I'm saying mother loving.
Oh yeah. The one that makes it a brand
through it. This stuff like that.
I'm like Sarit lives like, Gosh,
you're so fucking handcuffed. Yeah.
It's a perfect example of why working
clean is not funnier like that.
There's a perfect example. If you could
be actually talk like Katt Williams,
motherfucker and nigger come out of
his mouth every other word. I mean,
that's half of the appeal of this
crazy little dude. Yeah. You know,
it's like he's just, he's wild little
stoned out dude. That's, you know,
but Drake is good actor, man.
That was good impression.
Nancy grace wasn't bad either.
Yeah. I would like to see them.
I would like to see someone pull off
something like Saturday night live,
but be able to do it on the internet
or be able to do it on showtime or
somewhere where they just
leave them the fuck alone.
Like a, uh, a like a
multi-camera sketching like that.
Yeah. Like, could you imagine
if you're okay. By the way,
I don't even even know this
was a gentleman, you know,
Brendan cocreator of the Chappelle show.
Not a big deal.
One of the greatest sketch comedy shows,
in my opinion,
the greatest in the history
of the universe. Um,
but if you could do Chappelle show on
like HBO where you would just had full
reign, a hundred percent freedom.
God Damn, we kind of did though.
We just bleep it. Sorry a
little bit. Yeah, I mean,
but there are certain subject matter I'm
sure that they would have probably come
up to you guys against.
And I know you guys,
I'm experienced a lot of blow back
about uh, using the word Nigger, right?
That was not really, I mean that was
not that there was no, there was a,
they, Dave said there was, there wasn't.
So when Dave said that he was being
untruthful, yeah. Really? Yeah.
That's interesting.
Yeah.
There was like the first season there
was like a big symposium about it with
like should,
it was basically Viacom was saying like
should we allow people sang it on the,
on our air on bet,
MTV comedy central,
and they got sort of a few
black intellectuals and
Dave and fat Joe and Walter
Mosley and all these people to talk
about it and I so that they kind of were
like, what should we do? And they kind
of came to the conclusion of like, yeah,
if it's, if it contextually I set it
on comedy central the other night,
my special air the other night,
I said it eight times.
Why do you have that word eight times
and your specialist and find out then now
the mystery is complete.
Yeah. The suspense is in the
air. Ladies and gentleman,
you must go to direct us seat C.
Dot com and you but download my special,
which college, what's it
called? Women in black dude.
It's women and black dudes by Neil
Brennan. Hence the use of the n word.
Yeah,
but it's about me being called it
largely right by my black friends.
What that was like, et Cetera, et cetera.
So it's not like I'm out there like,
so these neurons, I'm not like going
the problem with the, you know, um,
did that frustrate you when they were
painting that picture when Chappelle was
in, in your opinion, in accurately
representing what happened? Yes.
I've said it almost like it's
gospel because I heard him say it.
No, well we've talked about it on
here. I don't, it's not what happened.
That's not what happened.
He and Dave actually watched or listened
to one of the episodes we did and he
was like, it was interesting,
but he wasn't like, he just,
that's just not what happened.
Well that's, yeah. Okay.
I'm doing a sketch show for comedy
central now that like, but I'm not,
I'm not worried about
being censored or anything.
It's just a matter of that's that
type of show is hard to do because a,
it's on NBC. They don't really, they
don't bleep stuff county central.
You can say fucking those, bleep it.
And if they played after midnight,
they won't believe it. Like mine aired
on midnight. I said, Fuck Shit, pussy,
all that shit. Um, and uh, but I'm doing
a sketch show, just a matter of like,
you got good premises or not.
I think
comedy central,
if any cable network is going to give
you freedom outside of HBO and showtime,
it's going to be comedy central.
I mean,
they have, the thing I always say
about comedy central, you know, when,
when Dave was saying that, that
they were, it's like, dude,
they've only made money on subversion.
They made money.
They made $1 billion on south park.
They made a 500 million on the daily show.
Another 400 million on Cole Bear.
Yeah. But that's not totally
accurate because I know
people who've done shows and
they've been pigeonholed and sensor,
and they'd been told not
to talk about this subject.
And then when Stan hope
and I did the man show,
we encountered a lot of
resistance. I mean, it was,
it was a real issue with
like what we wanted to do,
especially after Janet Jackson's
nipple came out. Right.
That literally will. Yeah. No, I know.
It's funny how big that was. Yeah.
I never would have thought that that
was going to be a big deal at all,
but it became a huge deal
with comedy central. I mean,
just a huge deal with everything.
Viacom, a huge deal with every network.
How would you tell us?
Yeah, there are 400 million
nipples in this country.
South Park is without a doubt,
the most deviant show of all time
comedy central is you have to get in,
you have to get lucky. I would say
when you look at Tosh Point, oh,
isn't that a perfect example? Super
deviant show. Super Hilarious.
And you have to get in and you have to
be proven popular before they can come in
and say like,
don't do that.
And you have to somehow get lucky
that they're not paying attention.
Well, it's also, you know, like
when South Park is deviant,
it's like they have a story,
they have a story and you have a purpose
and there's, there's something to it,
you know?
It's not like they're just trying to
put on some shock 'em rock 'em sock 'em
shit.
Yeah.
No, it's a narrative. It's fucking,
it's satire. It's the best. Yeah.
It's just the greatest fucking show of
all time. The Mormon. Yes, it was amazing,
but he's really good.
But it wasn't as good as
they're movies. My opinion,
their best stuff is their movies.
The a captain or a team team.
American America
and America is a fucking masterpiece.
One of the greatest movies of all time.
I totally agree. And people would think
we're crazy for saying it. They're crazy.
There are movies that God damn
piece of art. I totally agree.
It's so silly and ridiculous
and it's all puppets. So what?
You're allowed to do a lot of shit that
you can never getting out of the guy's
chest. Oh, how about the sex
scene? You know the uncut version,
he drops a log on her chest and
she drops along. It's unbelievable.
It's what a great fucking suck my Dick.
I'm going to,
you're going to have to suck my
dick. Okay. So yeah, the, the whole,
the actor saving the world part of
it. Oh, fucking mad payment. Yeah.
There's a weird though, cause Matt Damon
is actually smart, but I don't know.
We know the story by why they said that
because when they came out of like the,
the oven or whatever of the
puppet factory, they go,
he looks retarded.
So then they just started going
like Matt Damon and they were like,
let's just keep it, cause he looked
for Darren like they have nothing
against Matt Damon. Oh well you know
the comedy without victims. Very boring.
Right. Somebody's got to
take the head. Absolutely.
It's gotta be Matt Damon
to make a great show.
It's smashing or Matt
Damon doesn't give a shit.
He can't because he's not like
a pseudo intellectual like me.
He's actually a smart guy. Smart Guy.
Very smart guy. If you hear him talk,
you can't like pretend that he's
dumb cause then it didn't really,
that does look really dumb
though that day man. So rude.
Rude to poor Matt Damon.
He was good in that fucking the a,
the movie where he plays a super bad
guy. What does those, those movies,
the Bourne identity, he was
good in that. But the, the, the,
the new ones with Jeremy Renner,
who I think is awesome as well,
is so over the top that they've
gone so far. There's soap,
like he's jumping off buildings and shit
landed on people and twist their necks
and it's so ridiculously unbelievable as
far as like him being like that bad of
a bat.
Could you make this goes,
we've talked about this before.
Could you make a good action movie?
Could Joe Rogan make a good action
movie with real fighting physics?
Yes, no doubt. And it
should be, yeah, you don't,
you don't have to have like
ridiculous physics, you know?
And a lot of people like this is a weird
example because a lot of people think
he's a ridiculous guy, but go and
watch Steven Seagal first movie,
watch above the law. What he's
doing is all very possible. I mean,
he's not really doing
anything unbelievably stupid.
Like jumping off the top of the building
and twisting someone's neck with his
feet.
He's not doing anything dumb like that.
What he's doing is smashing people
with pool balls, breaking their arms.
He's doing a lot of shit.
Like I used that example.
I went in for a meeting once they had a
general meeting. This is when I was um,
just getting into comedy
and uh, I was, uh,
way more successful as a martial artist
than I was ever as a comedian back then.
And I just gotten an agent and they were
doing some action movie and they wanted
to make the new Steven Seagal they wanted,
that's what their idea was.
Steven Seagal had done this great big
crazy movie above the law and all these
studios were clamoring to find the next
mark could Stevens took off for a lot of
people that don't realize
was a martial artist.
He was the first American
to a run a Dojo in Japan.
It was respected martial artist who
was taken by whoever the fuck it was.
Some big shot studio guy said,
we're going to make this guy movie star.
And then so then they started looking at
all these martial arts and I went into
this meeting, these people, and
they were talking about, you know,
like what can you do,
can you,
you do flips and can you
do all this different shit?
And they were asking questions. I
was like, look, in a real fight.
That shit looks ridiculous.
Like one of the real problems with a
lot of these martial arts movies is that
they look ridiculous to martial
artists go, but they don't have to.
And I used above the law is a perfect
example. I go that I'm a martial artist.
I go, that is possible. All the
stuff that he's doing is feasible.
Like when you see a Jackie Chan movie,
God bless Jackie Chan,
he's a sweetheart of a guy.
He's a very talented martial artist.
I don't believe that God damn second
that he's jumping up and kicking two guys
in face at the same time.
I don't, I don't believe it. Yeah.
It doesn't happen in a real fight,
in a real fight. You, you
don't get a chance to get
punched 50 times in the face.
A little trickle of blood comes down the
side of your mouth. It doesn't happen.
It's not how it goes down.
And I think that it's possible to have
a movie that is the real life physics of
fighting and a real,
a real legitimate bad motherfucker
who fights a bunch of people off or
accomplishes something
that very difficult to do.
But it would be your observation
that in a real fight,
if you're finding eight guys,
they don't wait their turn,
they jump you Paul fucking, yeah, it's
not a retard wagon train one at a time.
Just waiting to karate stance for you
to turn her Pov tour and you know, look,
I'm kind of hypocritical because I love
kill bill and those are kind of silly in
that was sort of a way,
but it was,
I was willing to make that concession
with sword fighting and I was willing to
make that concession and you know,
and then there's a lot of fights with
Vivica Fox and hers kind of Real, right.
We're pretty gangster. And so as the
one in the trailer with her and um,
what's her fucking name?
It's not Vivek,
the White Woman One I Daryl Hannah.
Thank you Darryl Hannah.
That was pretty bad ass one of the
trailer when they're duking it out in the
trail and she pulls her other eye out.
That fucking movie was bad ass. But,
but I just, as a martial artist,
I understand what real fights look like
and I get upset when I see some shit.
That's just ridiculous. It wouldn't work.
Yeah, I probably shouldn't know. I know.
I mean,
I'm just wondering if that could be,
you know that Steven Seagal movie came
out in [inaudible] 88 you could make that
movie today exactly the same way. Just
make it a little bit more, you know,
updated for the Times that movie could
be done today if he was as young as he
was back then. And this is physically
adapt as he was back then and slim.
He was very slim. Yeah. Yeah.
I just wonder if everything's
has supercharged now.
It's like, could you, yeah, you could
do it. It just would have to be good.
The whole thing is just,
here's a perfect example.
Do you play any musical
instruments? No, I don't either.
So when I watch a guy who's doing
like a guitar solo in a movie,
he could be bullshitting.
I don't know if I'm watching like some
guys playing Jimi Hendrix and he's just
randomly doing things.
I don't know what he's doing.
I have no idea what he's doing so,
but if Eddie Bravo watches it,
he a Bravo knows how to play guitar.
He'll be like, that guy is bullshit. Yeah.
Also their fingers don't match. Exactly.
This is nonsense. That's how it is to me.
When I watch some guy who's just jumping
up and kicking a bunch of people and
doing a bunch of stupid shit,
that would never happen.
It was like a standup movies.
The same thing.
You Watch punchline just like thank
you very much. Perfect example.
But you watched funny people and you're
like, that's pretty much like stand up,
right?
Yeah.
Punchline was a very interesting movie
because it got a lot of people into stand,
standup comedy and,
but you remember when they had lockers?
Tom Hanks and Sally
lockers like a locker room.
When you go back and change like
this isn't a strip club. Okay.
It's a guy named comedy club. If
you're lucky. They have a green room.
Give me my lucky mic. Yeah, where's my,
yeah, if you lucky. They have a great,
did you have a lucky Mike?
No, but he might as well.
He might as well like
that's how realistic it was.
Yeah. That movie was not
legit. That was non legit,
but it got people interested in comedy.
I think a lot of people got into
comedy because of that movie.
Fans are comedians. People who wanted
to be a comedian after they saw that,
like at one a good movie like that.
Like I'm a movie like like rocky and
many people will start boxing after this
year.
Rocky.
You know how many people started playing
pool that joke with that many people
that talks to medially after
rocket? Yes, that's right. Italians.
He did a whole bit about Italians.
Which is dead on the money,
which is so fucking funny. That bit
way before Jersey shore, he nailed it.
The punchline is the
Moodle going to pay for it?
Uh, I mean a movie about anything where
it's really awesome and it's, it becomes,
well I haven't seen any of those military
movies where it's like sponsored by
the military. Well was lone
survivor. Anybody see that?
Very good. I haven't seen it, but
it's supposed to be very good. Um,
it might not be sponsored by,
but they certainly have to get approval
and then when they're portraying certain
events or people they have
to get approval. Yeah.
But these are like into,
I kind of have a thing right now where
I'm kind of anti war movies where I'm
just like,
it just feels like endorsing violence.
Well,
it kind of does,
but then it's also a legitimate form
of a genre of entertainment and yeah,
I'd always will be. You know,
war movies are always going
to be, you know, starting,
that's an aspect of life.
As long as it's this aspect of life,
there's going to be fascinating war movie.
How many guys, percentage do you
think guys that are in combat,
Iraq, Afghanistan, World War II, Korea,
Vietnam are there,
their life is kind of fucked afterward.
Percentage wise. Wow. You know,
as a person who's never served,
pts never wore all that shit.
I would be ridiculous to try
to give you a percentage.
I think it's pretty high though. I think
it's gotta be 40, 50, whatever it is.
Even if it's one guy, it's too many.
That's what I mean. It's so decimating.
Yeah.
I mean it's also something that we as
civilians sitting here talking on this
podcast could never really,
totally appreciate how devastating it
must be to be an 18 year old guy and also
in to find yourself over there and then
come back and try to reenter life after
dealing with six years of war
and craziness and Afghanistan
or, or what have you.
Um,
a lot of them get fucked up.
You know what's really wrong is that they
don't have nearly as much help as they
should. And like, one of the things that
we do for the, at the UFC is we, um,
we put on these fights for the
troops and we put them on for, um,
it's for the intrepid center
of excellence, which is a,
a center to treat traumatic brain
injury and they need money, man.
They need money all the time.
And, but it's, it's incredible.
They have money for all these weapons.
They have money for all this. Yeah.
You know, sending troops over there,
they have money to give them guns.
They have money for all this, these
drones and crazy surveillance technology.
But they have to raise money from
the public to treat these people with
traumatic,
something that's as big a problem if
not a, it's a much longer term problem.
Then having a,
it's like you need a gun for two years.
You need mental health coverage or a month
or healthcare sometimes for 60 years.
Yeah. And that's honestly, wives kind
of soured on war movies cause I'm like,
I just don't want to fucking
endorsed this. It's like
it's this decimates people.
Yeah, it certainly does.
There's no doubt about that.
But I think that if you want
to get people to be patriotic,
if you want to enforce the idea that
these people were over there fighting so
that we can enjoy freedom and safety here.
If that's the narrative,
then God dammit,
you better take care of those
fucking people when they come back.
And if you're not, then, then it makes me
feel like there's some shenanigans foot.
You know, you're, you're
fucking around here. Why?
You're not really thinking about the
health and safety of the people because
you're not thinking about the health
and safety of the very people that put
their lives in danger to do it.
So what is the real game here?
Where is the Rear Ma real motivation?
Are you trying to save money
by not funding this stuff?
Like why is there not more
money automatically going
in to take care of these
people if they really are
representing good? It's a fucking,
it's a dirty trick.
It's a dirty trick that patriotism
because it ropes in a lot of heroes.
Everyone all in. A lot of that's
for legitimate heroes who get used.
And you also hear guys that feel like they
get the switcheroo pulled on. Oh yeah.
Where you think it's got,
I mean, I think you could,
you could trick an 18 year old into
anything. You know what I mean?
Well, Pat Tillman the whole story.
Pat Tillman is a perfect example.
If you don't know that story, Pat
Tillman was a, it's a great documentary,
by the way. What's it called? The
Tillman store. I haven't seen it.
Oh Dude. It's fucking, his brother's
in it. His family. It's amazing.
I'll see you tonight. Yeah, fuck it. Um,
but Tillman is a fantastic story because
that's a perfect example of a real hero
who got roped into something.
I mean,
that guy was a NFL quarterback or an NFL
football player who was a star player
with a fucking perfect face.
Beautiful genetics is full.
All American man who blowing thick hair,
perfect alpha male.
So he realizes that the United States
has been attacked and decides that it
being a football player is bullshit.
What I want to do is defend my country.
He's a real hero, goes over to
Afghanistan and finds a luster. Fuck.
Yeah.
Just an unbelievable cluster
fuck criticizes it openly
and is ultimately killed
in friendly fire in it. His last words
were, I'm fucking Pat Tillman. Allegedly.
Yeah. And then he gets shot
by, by US troops. Like the
whole thing is a disaster.
Right. And um, his brother
has openly spoke about that,
about how angry they were at pat for
being so critical and openly critical.
It's a crazy story,
but it's a story.
Ultimately the real tragedy
is not just the loss of life,
which is of course tragic,
but that a real hero got
roped into something stupid.
A real hero got roped into this situation
where it wasn't organized correctly.
Where was all this chaos, which is just,
you're going to have in war anyway. Yeah.
According to him it was terrible.
So they, they got a real hero and,
and got them stuck in
this terrible quagmire.
Yeah. But I don't think he's
any more heroic than any,
any other kid who enlists of course. You
know what I mean? Like course not. But,
and then they get over there
and they're like, oh, this is,
this is more way more like a
prison than I thought it would be.
Well,
of course he's not any more heroic.
But what's great about that
story is he had already achieved,
want go looking for millionaire.
He's a star athlete,
he's in the Goddamn NFL.
And then he decides to go overseas and
ultimately loses his life. You know,
that's the reality of war.
And that's what I think a lot of us miss
on the outside when you're looking at
it as far as like a, a, a creative
narrative as far as, you know,
looking at it as like a movie, looking
at it. And you know, I mean the, the,
the movie, the market mark movies actually
based on a real guy, Marcus with trail,
lone survivor. It was,
apparently the book's amazing.
So it's based on a real guy
and he's decimated. He's got PTSD,
he's got, he's, I mean he's his,
his, his, he's got some severe
mental health, a nice guy.
I met him saying nothing.
I bet. Yeah, I met him a couple times in
the UFC. He's a very nice guy. You know,
there's a program where you can leave
tickets from military to do that.
Leave tickets. You can set up.
Kathy Grover told me about this.
There's a thing where you can set aside
a however many tickets for your shows
and donate them to military guys and
then they can decide what shows they want
to go to. Really. Yeah. And
I can't remember the name of
it. Tell me after the show.
I'll text. Yeah, that sounds great.
That sounds like a great idea. Yeah,
it's probably a good idea to set aside
some for poor students to, you know,
I totally agree. Yeah. You know,
good idea you do on Broadway.
Some for girls who can't get laid, you
know, where does it end, Joe? I Dunno.
Probably like a old lady. She
yell, don't give them tickets.
Hit to get to
get to a certain group and caught him off.
You know?
So while your specials out now
it's a, you can download it. Yeah.
Comedy central.com. direct.cc a first
special ever. First special. And you know,
a lot of people don't know. You were
really wearing a standup comic? No.
And you decided that night decided
six, six and a half years
ago. What made you decide, uh,
just cause you just get told that if
you're writing, well first of all,
there's a couple of things.
If you're co, you know,
Showbiz and comedy is like a
bit of a caste system in the,
in the medieval sense,
like there are stars,
the comedians and then there are like
below that there's writers and if you're
just a writer, you're,
you're hoping, you're like,
hey, it's a lot of
like, what do you think?
You never really get to decide you're you,
it's just this all,
you're always looking up.
So I just was like, and,
and then there's also the thing of stars
get more power just to get projects
made, what they want to do, et
Cetera, et cetera. So I was like,
I'd rather take a shot at being on camera
then constantly having to be trying to
convince studios that I'm funny or trying
to convince a performer that this is a
good joke.
Or,
and also the thing with day was like
we were in a partnership and then I
realized like, oh,
partnerships are fleeting.
So Matt and Trey are
great. Yeah, yeah. Uh,
but they can be fleeting.
So I was like,
let me just try to do some shit on my own.
And the standups been good for that and
I'm doing a couple of pilots and people
are paying attention.
Good for you dude.
You know,
it's cool to see someone who's smart
who figured that out, who just said,
you know what, I could do this too. And
I've always said that to people. Like,
you know, people say, oh, I
can never be a comedian. Well,
if you never could be a comedian,
you can never be a comedian.
But there are some people that could be
a comedian that just don't ever do it.
And a lot of them are writers.
There's a lot of really funny writers
that just don't, they just don't,
and it's funny with
writers, writers, Simi,
they almost talk to me like a runaway
slave. You made a cross a line.
I was making that joke with a buddy.
My Buddy Alex pays,
who's like the best writer on weekend
update and he's going with Seth to the new
show and he writes like all of Amy and
Tina Shit and the Oscars and the and
knowledge and he's fucking great writer.
He wrote that intro for
at the Golden Globes.
It was an intro for Leonardo
Dicaprio. It was a, and like a,
a uh, a supermodels. Vagina.
Please give a warm welcome
to Leonardo Dicaprio.
He's a fucking hilarious guy.
Bays craze on Twitter.
Bay's crazy.
Be a z and then craze,
c r a. Z. E. Nice. Um,
but he, we were joking,
he was the other day where it was like,
you ain't never going to be nothing.
They might let you shoot a pre tape. You
may you direct something, but fuck that.
That's all you,
that's as far as you're going to get.
Like there's just a thing with writers
where we feel like we're, and it's like,
no, it's like, I'll be on shows
with a bunch of comedians.
I'll do just as well as them and they'll
throw deals at them and I'm kind of
like, why did we just got the same
response? What are you talking about?
I'll be on like showcases at the
laugh factory. Yeah, laugh factory,
the empire or whatever, and
for the longest time I do
just as well as everybody,
but like showbiz would be
like, well, you don't really,
you're not really a comedian because you
know how to write and direct. It's like,
no, I'm just as much a comedian as
pretend I can't write and direct.
I did just as well as this guy
that you want to have on your show.
I, but you understand that when someone
is appealing in a certain way that they
want to put them on a show,
they might be different than you and
they might be looking for a specific time
that you know that's a real issue that
comics have was like, what about me? Yeah,
I might not getting mine. Well,
they don't have a place for you.
They're not interested in you.
They don't find you to be compelling
data sitting in this role.
Then the lily is young,
cute guy that happens to be gay and
he's going to play a sitcom character.
You're not that guy.
The people that have had a lot of
success, like Louie, Tina Fey there.
Pete people weren't Larry.
David people weren't casting them,
but they don't have to see this
idea of like you have to be,
the beautiful thing about being a standup
is all you'd have to do is do what
you're already doing a grade.
That's the beautiful thing about it.
It frees you from this weird system
where you're constantly auditioning for
things. Yeah, and hoping and praying
to get accepted and then, yeah,
I think that fucks with
people's heads too, man.
I don't think it's good to
get rejected all the time,
especially when you're
unbelievably insecure.
That's the thing is I would have movie
ideas or jokes and they'd be like, no,
that's not funny, and I'd be
like, I think that's funny. Yeah.
I'm going to go to a comedy
club and test that out.
Well think about half the shit you guys
did on the Chappelle show and trying to
pitch those things,
like
trying to bomb.
I remember pitching before we started the
show and they pitch and they'd be like,
the fuck are you talking about?
It's hilarious.
What are you talking like just constantly
like Chapelle has a theory that you
can never,
a joke never works.
A standup joke is never works
during the day to people.
You know what I mean?
That's what good does it work?
Telling it to someone during the day,
which is like kind of true.
Like you just have to try,
you have to work it out and then
you have to go try it. Uh, but,
but yeah, so it's like figuring out, it's
like, it's like standup is the, it's the,
it's a leveler where you just go like,
no,
I think I'm pretty good and I'm
going to go test that out. And yeah,
it definitely gives you
an avenue that you don't,
you don't need other people's
acceptance and approval.
And when you're trying
to create something,
generating something
where a piece of artwork,
a comedy sketch and thinking about someone
else's approval while you're doing it
is the kiss of death.
You don't want to think about that.
You just want to think what does Neal
Brennan think is funny. How do I do?
And that's the beautiful thing about
doing stand up. You can do that.
You can do that. Ready?
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome Neil Brennan. Yeah,
you go on stage and that's all you man.
You don't have to worry about
passing things through producers.
Fruit by the network.
Okay. Think of it. And the
other thing is different.
Tween standup and movies and TV shows.
I can think of a joke right now.
Tell it tonight and know
if it's good or not.
Whereas I think of a joke
for a movie, it'll be a year
and a half. Oh yeah, Friday.
No,
it fit even kind of works.
You know there's a real problem too in
that comics for for whatever reason it's,
and it's all because of money.
We thought they thought that
you have to do something else.
You have to do for awhile as a city. For
some guys it was the talk show. Yeah.
They,
they were in it to get in,
to use it as a means to an end instead
of like really enjoying it for what it
actually is.
It's just an amazing
Saint Epson incredible thing, man. That's
the thing that people don't realize.
It's like you're part preacher, you're
part philosopher, you're part clown.
It's like so many things.
You can change people's thought process
in a way that you can't in very many
ways and you're going SAS,
it's great
you can them and I'm one
of the most powerful forms ever,
like a good comic on stage killing to
me is still the favorite thing I like to
watch is my most enjoyable thing to,
to sit there and take in
because it's just the,
the feeling that you get from laughing
your fucking ass off at a great standup.
Do you don't really get that from a lot
of other places. No. It's also visceral.
It's that like person on person and
I think that's, that's more, uh,
needed.
I think.
Like the reason Stanhope stone better
like culturally is because everything's so
like isolated and you can just
download everything and it's like, no.
A person in front of you doing
something is really vital and I think
even more vital when you're
in a small club. Yeah.
I think I do a lot of larger places lately
and I enjoy them because it's like a
more powerful experience.
Like when I'm doing the Chicago theater
Friday and it'd be like 3,400 people on
that. Yeah. And when you're on stage and
3,400 people are screaming and laughing,
it's take theater. Woo. It's
a crackling feeling then.
But you know what else is bad ass?
The God little room at the Ice House,
that 80 seat room. Woo. That's
a great fucking room, man. Yeah.
That little room stuffed with
people is so intimate and so alive.
It's almost the better form of comedy.
It's almost the better
form as an audience member.
And the better form is
a PR as a performer,
you're intimate with all those 80 people,
man.
Yeah. It goes back to the dog smelling
thing. It's not like it's all right
right there.
Here's something for people don't know
about dogs and their powerful sense of
smells is a perfect way to,
to kind of sense it or to get it in
your head because a lot of people go,
oh well dogs can smell x parts per
million, you know, and they really can't.
That's how they track people.
Skunks, skunks are one,
a few animals that human beings have the
ability to smell in a small parts per
million. I was that true?
Yeah. That's why when skunks,
skunk smell is so potent to us that uh,
Scott could be like a block
away and squirt someone,
you'll fucking smell it clear as day.
This is nothing a block away.
It's like a little, uh,
little dog shit thing.
Scored something out and the
little tiny amount. Yeah.
I wonder why that is evolutionarily.
Probably to keep this Chicago alive.
What's that? Software updates. Yeah.
They updated the shit out of that o s
till it got to the point where they had
the most devastating antiviral
software error, I'm sure.
Just trying to think like
who is it benefiting? It's
benefiting. Keeps this and,
but the fact that humans can smell
it so well, keep away from them.
We were horrified by it,
so they hit the tune that we also evolved.
It's like the version of a dog whistle.
It's a smell version of a dog whistle.
You blow a dog whistle. Dogs can hear it.
People can't.
That smell is like they hit the right
tune where we're like that fucking shitty
smell that comes out of there. But
we're like, whoa. It's like the
perfect smell.
So you think human beings,
do you think that will ever evolve out
of that smell of not caring about that
smell?
The only way that would be possible.
It was a skunks were fucking delicious.
Skunks tasted like lobster.
If every school, it was like, yeah,
you got to shoot them before
they blast you with the stink.
But if you can get a head shot on him,
God damn, they're delicious. Yeah,
like little crabs. They're like stone
crabs. Yeah, no, you're probably right.
And then we would figure out a way,
million, it would take millions of years.
Take a long time.
We get there.
Who is thinking about the things that
have happened and what are the odds of
them evolving? Like the
Angler fish, the fish.
There's a fucking fishing pole grown out
of his head and a little word dangling
in front of it and a fish sees that
Laura and then gets, gets eat. Ah, fuck.
Did that evolve?
Yeah.
Do you ever see that pull that
pull a video of an angler fish up?
That is one of the weirdest
things in all of nature,
that nature figured out a God damn
fishing pole before people did. Yeah.
I mean a person invented a
fishing pole because they go, hmm,
I need to figure out how to get over
there in the water and drop this down.
Look at this God damn thing. It's got
a fishing rod grown out of its face.
This is one of the weirdest,
silliest things ever. Oh,
this is just a bunch of
different weird things, man.
She should just find one that's just
an angler fish killing a angler,
fish killing and other fish.
It's,
it's so bizarre because they trick the
fish to coming close because if it's
fishing rod,
it's got to lure and the end of its
face and then the fish comes in and gets
eaten somehow or another through.
And it's amazing that they did that
in the 6,000 years since the Bible was
written less than 10 for sure.
I mean that's what the Bible says.
That's fucking in that amazing.
Yeah, and it's amazing.
It's amazing how many people believe
that less a 47% of Republicans,
46% of people in a recent Gallup
poll said they believe the,
in the biblical creation version
of look at that. There it is,
which means that the earth is
less than 10,000 years old.
See it sitting here like this
and then watch is a little fish,
all of their soccer and m to do in that.
That's a fish on a stick,
but check it out when his
little thing comes up. Oh,
this is new moon shot is that
thing on his forehead. Yeah.
That's the lore and it comes out
here once you vet these in advance.
So I don't have to sit here
pulling our decks, get to see,
get them to use that God damn thing.
You use your thing. You fuck you're,
you're making me look bad kid.
This is my friend.
This is your video. There he is. There
he is. Look at that. Shaking it. Look,
he's tricking him. He's trying to trick
them with his lore. That's a bad example.
This, I'm sure there's a way
better video than that online.
Now you know how we felt when we
play the Drake video? I understand,
but you saw the Drake video. I didn't see
that. There's one out there. That's good.
Yeah, but we memorized it. I
mean we had, we had in our head,
we wanted to please your
job. Don't you say? Well,
there's so many animals that like how,
how does a certain animal develop?
It's called how's the leopard developed?
It's wild skin with it's fucking
amazing. What does that, why is,
why is that there? You know,
why? Why does, uh, you know,
why does a tarpon look like that?
Why did you know my name
is fucking strange animals
that live on this earth. LF.
Yeah. All giraffes. Elephants.
Yeah. It's fun. It's crazy.
At 6,000 years it didn't take long
for God. I mean it's quick. Yeah.
Well one year the Lord, you've got that
kind of power guy that got it. Yeah. Yeah.
That's funny that that's like,
that can get you in trouble.
Like if you were on a show,
like say if you on an NBC show
and she started mocking the Bible,
there'd be a bunch of groups.
That was a problem.
The,
you know what's funny though is it's the,
and I've been talking about this
and a lot of like, it's that guy.
It's that Gotcha Shit. Or like, hey NBC,
I heard Neil Brennan and Joe Rogan.
We're talking about God you might want to
do so. I was like eight times. Exactly.
Really wants to know what's funny though.
I only only free people
objected on Twitter.
Well it's just this, you don't have a
lot of followers. She had more followers.
How many followers? I think I got
challenged this fucking guy. Challenges.
I'd say you have at least
200,000 you're good to 38 yeah.
There you go. I here. That's
a lot of followers. It's
very good. That's very good.
But people don't pay attention
to you generally that's
what's going on. They say,
oh it's Neil tweet and I just
pass over that. I only follow them
fucking, I don't want to fall
black dates close enough.
Yeah, he's, he's the the bridge.
Neal Brennan's the bridge. Yeah.
People love to complain about Shit Man.
Whether it's valid or not,
they love to get people on things.
Well,
I always say it's way easier to do that
then fucking actually do something.
It certainly is and you know it's also
is weird to 38 ladies and gentlemen
almost to 39 we can get
it to two 39 by the way.
Neil Brennan with n e n e a l B r e n.
N. A. N. Go there, follow
him. Show him the love.
Can we see this happen in real time?
Ladies and gentleman,
we are running out of spaces.
Need how many we need route nine more.
Nine more than we can do is
we're going to refresh this.
We're going to get nine more insight. We
are. We've got an eight more. We had one.
We got one in the time. It took me
to say that sentence. We got to,
I feel like I'm on the home shopping club.
What's,
go back to that in a little bit.
Um, actually we need a 109 more. Oh,
that's nothing. We got that. I can't
remember. Why is it, I can't read that.
Why is it blurry when
it's on that big screen,
but it's clear when
it's on your laptop now.
Weird like numbers are separate pixel
thing. Is that what it is? Yeah.
Two 38 94 yeah. Okay, so
we have 116 we need to,
how many will you go down a look at
my last hot tweet in a hot one. Damn.
It just jumped crazy style.
Now we just need a,
it's kind of insulting that they
weren't following me before that. Yeah.
You know what I mean? It's like, Hey,
fuck you guys. Hey. Rude. Like fuck.
You know what? I'm going to, I'm going
to reserve judgment on this clown.
He hasn't convinced me yet.
Teach Bell podcast twice already.
Jumped up to 47 six again,
this is absolutely incredible.
That's Neil Brandon power.
Any a. L. B. R. E. N. N.
I will say whatever. I'm on the road,
man. Every road, every road show.
I do have someone, at least one person
says they've heard on here. Oh, that's
cause you're good. You did
a good job. You're thinking,
thank you. I'm happy. I know.
Yeah,
we did it.
Oh, exciting guys. But
keep going though. I just,
because we hit. Don't,
don't do it all back off.
Now let's take this momentum
and keep going. Oh, it's funny.
There's somebody said this douche
blocked me. Neil Brennan. Oh,
I will block the shit out of
pal. I love block and paypal.
Well, you know what, man,
you really should black people.
You shouldn't argue with them because
I've seen people like save rude, rude,
rude shit to people and then
someone responds. But yeah,
I got you to respond to I when I've seen
that, I seen that many times. Some kid
made today. I had the,
I had to tweet the kid,
the guy who yelled at the end of
the football game for Seattle.
I don't know about that, but do you
know that Guy Robert? What's happened?
Richard Sherman, I wrote
it, I wrote a, he got, he,
the big thing today was that he
yelled at the end of the game, but he,
during an interview, but he was
basically like, fuck you. You know,
he didn't say fuck you, but he just was
like very bump asset. Right. And uh,
so I had a tweet about it today
and some kid wrote like, dude,
that was yesterday, so you're, you failed.
And I just wrote Idm them. I said,
hey man, don't tell me about comedy.
Did you really? Yeah, I wrote, I've
gotten 500 retweets and five minutes,
listen,
why would you want that guy
talking about it on the podcast?
Because they think that they think you
don't smoke weed. That's what's going on.
They think that they think
that they can insult people.
This is what you should do when
someone says something like that.
Do you go aw sweetie. And then
block them. Yeah. I also do that.
Most of the time I'll just block this kid,
this kid in particular ticket
where I had to go out of his,
I had to go out of pilot
for my comedy centers.
We'll show is I'm going to make sketches,
I'm going to and I'm going
to be in him a ride them,
direct them and then I'm going to put
them on an iPad and go around to people on
the street and just say, Hey, do you
think this is funny? And if they don't,
I'll argue with them. And if
they do then it's, and if they,
and I'll stage arguments between
someone who doesn't think it's funny and
someone who does think it's funny,
I want to do it.
What? Wait a minute. You're
show is to take a pilot,
put on an IPAD and I'll go take a sketch,
right.
Put it on an iPad and then
just go up to get a bus stop.
Say you think this is funny
and then argue with him.
If he doesn't think it'll be fine.
I promise you,
it'll be funny cause I get in arguments
all the time about something not being
funny. It's, it'll be
fucking funny. I promise it.
In so many arguments about things not
being funny that you've decided to make a
show arguing that things are fun.
I did a thing on Twitter where I,
right, I posted a joke where I said, hey,
I'm going to do this joke later tonight
and a club. Do you think this will work?
Okay?
And a bunch of likes swimming up river.
And I just think know what
makes you laugh is with comedy,
people never say like, that's not
my taste. They go, that's not funny.
It's this declaration. It's this
declaration. In fact, that makes me crazy.
Right? But here's the
problem. Go to them the right.
I know that's what's interesting. But
then they should say, in my opinion,
and they never do.
Oh, okay. So you just one with those
three words, your show gets eliminated.
Yes. In my opinion, yes. Oh yeah. My
opinion. That's not funny. Neil brand.
And then they go, I go, I literally
go, thank you for saying it that way.
You're correct. Oh, okay. So now
if they go, that's not funny. I go,
what do you think?
And here's the other thing I'll do.
If they have a better way to make it
better, I will reshoot the sketch.
So would this is essentially is your,
uh,
it's a really sneaky way to
get people to learn manners
in essence. Yeah. And it's also
taking people to task for, so,
so I said, I posted a joke on Twitter.
I go, do you think this will work?
A bunch of comedy writers were like,
that's a good joke. That'll work.
That'll work. Some kid wrote some,
no name k goes hundred percent bomb.
You know what I mean? Like just this
factual thing and it makes me crazy.
And then when I did the joke
later and it worked, he never,
no, just setting yourself up to be trolled
so hard right now. Do you realize that?
But are you really sending a trap? This
is lot. It's taking trolls to task.
I'm doing lot. It's a live chat
room. I want to believe you,
but I'm not sure I do. I want to believe
that you're doing this on purpose.
But I kinda think that that's just what
you do and then you are enjoying your
embracing it. He goes, you just embracing
the fact that I'm argumentative. Yes.
And even with trolls like
you like so what, so what
are you trying? What I never,
I don't, I don't address people online. I
don't go like, fuck you guy. I'm going to,
I don't like [inaudible] you only go
personal DM if I'm gonna yeah, I will do.
Sometimes they'll DM and
go, hey, just so you know,
here's why I'm locking you blocked.
Oh Wow. That's what I did today.
That why do you do that? Uh, I think,
I think that they can't believe that
someone is listening to them and you just
go like, Hey, I'm here.
I saw what you said.
That's sweet.
So you're going to hurt my guy who answers
the message in the bottle. But yes,
the message in the bottles cunty so
you send them a message back, fuck you,
I'm going to break your bottle next time
I see it. Never fuck you. It's just,
hey man, that's not necessary.
He's the one that feeds the troll.
So now that they go to, you didn't
start doing that and they meet a chart.
He's like one of those assholes that
feeds bears and then you go camping.
They rip your fucking tent apart because
fucking Neil Brennan was the last last
week giving them cookies. Exactly. You're
fucking it up for everybody else buddy.
You know, what do you want me to do? I
don't want you to do anything other than
email running. Don't worry about the
24 seven. I'm just analyzing you.
I just put you into a category though.
One for what is it?
Argumentative and self defeating.
Troll feeder. I dude, I really don't.
I never respond to trolls. Everyone.
I love blocking people. Okay.
Cause I, cause I believe in justice
will. Since you enjoy going on Twitter,
let's ask Twitter. Do you think
Neil Brennan is a troll feeder?
Here we go. Let's see. Ah, this is a
term, you know, we just invented it.
I'm going to say is feeder. What does
that mean? I instigate them. Yes.
Okay,
okay.
Please respond. I don't, but go ahead.
You look at my timeline. I don't, I don't,
I don't.
Thanks in advance guys.
I'm my records and I
mean all that in advance.
This is from the heart, sweetie. Let's
see. Let's see what the responses.
I would say 100% are they gonna say
yes, he's on. These are your people.
Your fucking goading them don't have
people in my friend. They're just people.
They're just regular people
who 238,000 Twitter followers.
20 not 239 I don't feel like I own them.
Okay,
so I don't feel like there might be.
I know what they're going
to want to agree with you.
The prone to want to read with you,
your people,
they're prone to want
to agree with you there.
There's small minded people
who would never disagree. Oh,
how I get them to my side. I
challenged them. Small minded.
They don't want to challenge Joe.
They they want to go,
what do we get one now Joe?
Fuck this troll feeder.
You are troll feeding right now.
You're trolling trolling you.
That's what's great about this.
This is a trick troll. Uh,
you would like to think that it's a trick
troll. That's like someone saying, Hey,
I didn't want to win. The first
place meant to fall down. Who?
I know what you're doing, dude, because
I'm not six. Okay. You're not tricking me.
Yeah, you're a troll feeder. It's
almost universal. Wow. This is crazy.
I'm getting hammered, Bro.
Hammered. Like, what did anyone say?
I look like I've ain't yet
rude things about necessary.
That's not necessarily how, how's
the meth? Meth is a big one for me.
People are rude, man.
Neil brands, my friend.
Anyone don't need to fucking,
I watched this special, eh?
Yeah.
It's never going to happen for this guy.
You should just be a writer.
They're being mean man,
of course. But that's how,
that's how they get your youtube
show. That's how I get them. Yeah.
That's how that now they've got my
attention. It's like a girlfriend.
I can't wait for this to end.
She can so we can go on the line.
I can't wait to get home to my computer
and really the girlfriend argue just so
that you can make up. That's where it
is. What they're really being mean.
They really love you.
This is a trailer show the trailer.
Then I moved to New York.
Sorry.
I have a black dudes
pounds.
[inaudible] I don't know them.
They just are here.
Barely qualified.
You're so lights came of that
[inaudible]
yeah, so I got a lot of black
friends. I have like over uh,
over 20. Now. It's like almost 30. No,
I got a lot of black friends.
Here's the thing about my black friends.
My black friends can relax in a way that
my white friends can't wipe and we're
not very good at relaxing.
You know why I figured it out?
Cause we're always worried about the
rules and who's breaking the rules.
The other thing about being white got
admitted. We got tattletale and our DNA.
We got snitch in our blood. White people
are in a nightclub of my black friends.
It'll be packed. Everybody's drinking,
dancing, laughing and having a great time.
And I'm trying to fit in like there
must be 350 people in here right now.
I wonder what the fire marshal
would have to say about it.
White people love the rules so much that
we will go on police ride alongs for
fun. Vinnie idea white. That is
your, and try to explain that.
Blind people like, yeah. I called the
precinct to say, hey, this is Neil.
I'm white and I like
to go for a ride along.
They send over a squad car.
I get in the backseat,
which is fun for me because what other
opportunity would I had to do that?
No
make you uncomfortable while
was not really, I like, I'm
joy that you like watching yourself.
No, I just, I'd like those jokes. No,
they're very good Joe.
Yeah. It's funny. Yeah.
It's totally true about
the ride along thing too.
That is a weird aspect you're allowed
to do. I want to go, first of all,
it's fucking dangerous as hell.
The idea that you're going to go,
cops die every year.
Every day.
You're going to go in the back of a cop
car while they investigate crimes and
that's going to be fun. Educational?
No, just just for enjoyment. Yeah.
I love law and order. You have to pay to
do it. No, I think it's just like you're,
if I think it's really got to know a cop,
you should have to pay and it's probably
better than watching cops on TV if you
just get really stoned and going
to work right around there.
Cops should be able to give it
to you for free if they want to.
But ordinarily I think that people do it.
They should,
the money should go to jazz up the
precinct by some new toilet paper or
something. Yeah. Girly calendar
or something like that. They have,
can't have girly calendar. So at the
precinct they can think about that now.
It's like a gas station thing. Can't
really have them at the precinct. Yeah.
That you can cause a
female cop. Yeah. Yeah.
A buddy of mine used to
do a thought experiment,
which is if you call nine one
one, it was, he was like, it was,
it was a female inferiority thought,
thought, uh, experiment. But it's like,
would you rather a female copper male cop?
I don't think it's just
like unequivocally you,
Malcolm. Um, I guess, is that true?
I'm sure there would be a scenario
that you would want a female cop.
What would that be?
Domestic, domestic violence?
No, not violence. The domestic
disturbance. Like A, if you're,
I think if your girl's acting crazy,
you want a girl.
Although you could make a case that a
girl really acting crazy or the girl might
make them act more crazy.
You wouldn't want to dude,
who understands what it's like to
have a girl acting crazy on you. Okay.
I don't know. I don't cause I don't think
that a female cops going to be like,
then what did he do? You know
what I mean? Like I don't really,
it might make the woman
relaxed more of a woman.
That's interesting.
I would think that would
be the total opposite.
If I was a guy and um,
my girl was going crazy and throwing
shit at me and the cop showed up,
I would hope that a guy would show
up where I would go, dude, I look,
I shouldn't be with her. I
understand that. I fucked up.
I picked a bad relationship. But you see
what the fuck's going on back then? Yeah.
It just ain't me, man. I would
cause the grill. We're going to go.
What'd you say to make her do that?
Well, yeah, but there's also a case that
women hate women more than men hate women
sometimes,
but women hate men too that are assholes
and especially if you're a chick cop
and you have to deal
with so many shitheads,
that's the problem of being a cop is it?
You have to do with so much craziness.
It's a human garbage men,
and you literally have to clean up
human garbage all you have to just,
you're the handyman for the earth.
Everyone's lying to you
because everybody went, thanks.
You're going to want to put them
in a cage and everywhere you go,
they know you're armed.
You know you're allowed to carry a
gun everywhere and no one else is.
The whole thing is madness.
The idea of being a cop and just keeping
your shit together and hoping that they
don't get absolutely
crazy. You know, and Ptsd.
We're talking about that with soldiers
soon. Think about that with cops.
That's a huge problem.
Huge.
Well that's like where they were beating.
They were,
they found out what they were,
they would beat guys when they
caught them during a car chase.
Cause there's so hopped up on
adrenaline horse and they just fucking,
they have to do some with it and fucking
scared man. Scary fucking life. Yes.
Driving a hundred miles an hour.
It's like that's scary. Yeah.
And then you have a gun and
you have to subdue a guy and
it's an inefficient system. The whole cops
and robbers, good guy, bad guy system.
It's inefficient.
It seems to be,
there's gotta be a better way to keep
track and keep a society on track to be,
keep people kind,
keep people law abiding.
It doesn't seem like that the violence
versus violence version of me,
it feels necessary to protect
people and to stop bad guys,
but it's not the best system.
There's gotta be a better system.
I think we're going to look back on this
one day the same way we look back on
like stupid shit they did in the Middle
Ages or stupid shit they did back when
during the renaissance needs to
cover piano legs cause they thought
brought back sided two people. Do you
have you talked about that before? Sure.
Yeah cause I want people to know that
that's like one of my favorite old timey
thing.
They used to do that.
So that's why there's skirts
on on a certain table.
Yeah. Certain table legs
they would put skirts on,
they'd put skirts on piano leg sometimes
because they thought
people were going to fuck
piano.
Yeah.
And I wonder why they were so desperately
trying to stop people from fucking,
maybe they were running out of food
and they didn't want somebody baby.
I think religion,
I think normally it's just pure.
It was probably like the
puritans or something.
Yeah. And it's also, they're always
coming from this point of a suppression.
You know,
there was coming from trying to stop
you from doing all the craziness that
you're doing,
but the idea that they were going to lock
things down so tightly that they were
going to put pants on table legs,
like those are people,
man.
People thought that it's totally
inefficient way of handling things.
We know that now.
I think one day we're going to look back
at the whole cops and bad guys thing.
We're going to say the same,
but what do you, what fucks, what do you,
what do you think that and a possible
evolution could be? It would have to be a,
a, an F. Which part of it? I
guess it's just arresting people.
Um,
well all the above.
I think we automatically assume that
people are going to commit crimes.
They're going to commit violent crimes,
are going to commit
violent actions and salt.
We automatically just assume
that about people. But we do so,
so much less per capita than we
ever have throughout history now.
And so if you follow that trend,
ultimately,
whether it's a hundred years from
now or a thousand years from now,
there's got come a point in time where we
don't have to worry about that anymore.
How long will it take?
I don't know, but I see,
if you look back on the way people lived
in the 12 hundreds the way people lived
at 2000 BC or what we suppose they lived,
but life was much more dangerous,
much more violent, much more chaotic.
You're much more likely to get murdered.
I think that if you follow that
logic at a certain point in time,
especially when you fall,
you see that
you think you're more likely
to get murdered back then,
most definitely much my
average person's murdered
from every everything,
murder or assault.
I think you're much safer today then
you probably have been at any time
ministry. I actually think that
that's true, but I think that,
I think that it has a lot. I don't
know if that's human evolution so much.
It's just better. A better long
crime, crime and punishment system.
Ooh, I doubt that. Because the crime and
punishment system is completely corrupt.
And there's private prisons that,
oh dude, fucking awful. But I think that
that's the reason. I mean it's, it's,
it's as evil. That movie I
recommended the house I live in. Yes,
it's criminal enterprise. Watch
that movie, the House I live in,
it's fucking amazing
profit off of putting people in jail
and you could therefore petition or um,
uh,
you know,
spend money and lobby to make sure that
laws are kept in place so that you can
ensure that more people
will be put in prisons.
The idea that that's true is terrifying.
That there's someone out there that's
a vampire and they're sucking the blood
out of people by putting them in cages.
And when you put them in cages,
you profit off that.
So what you want to do is make it so
it's written down on paper somewhere that
you're allowed to put people in cages.
Even if there's this huge tidal wave of,
of, of, of attention that is supporting,
making things legal that are not
hurting anyone like marijuana.
There's still people lobbying
these vampires lobbying
to make sure that it stays
illegal and that that
punishment is enforced on the
people that commit, you know,
these quote unquote crimes,
these crimes that hurt. No one,
I disagree with you that I,
I don't think people are any more moral
than they were a thousand years ago.
I don't know.
Sin didn't say that more and
more, all I say it's safer. Um,
I think that they're more educated
and if you're more educated,
you have more access to information,
you're more likely because of the
fact that you have more information.
You're more likely to make an intelligent
choice than you ever have in the past.
I don't think it means that people are
always going to make intelligent choices,
but I think you're more likely to make
an intelligent choice then back when they
were drowning people, cause they all
thought they were witches. You know,
now people don't have that as an excuse.
They know there aren't any fucking witches
and so they're less likely to drown
someone in a fit of hysteria because you
worried that some crazy bitch is gonna
put a hex on your kids and they
get cancer. I think that's fact.
And if you look at that trend,
that's an information trend that's a
trend of we have more access to the truth.
We have more access to just raw data
and information and we also have more
information that shows all the corruption,
all the problems with
various power systems.
You know about that stat
that the higher the,
the fewer basically the
more education women get,
the fewer babies there are in the country.
It's one of my favorite things.
Like the best, it's the best. The best
contraception contraceptive is sensation.
Yeah.
Well that's also in cities
per capita, they, uh,
the people in cities per capita tend
to breed less as they get more and more
successful.
Well,
they were saying that that's one of the
things that people who are against the
idea that human population
is going to explode.
One of their main points of reference
and argument is that human population
declines when conditions improve and
that when you're dealing with conditions
where life is fleeting, people
are poor, everyone's dying.
People have a tremendous
amount of children.
Then when these places
industrialized and start to thrive,
then there becomes less and less children
and that in fact we might reach a
trend, a tipping point someday where
the population starts to decline.
I was talking to a buddy of mine about
the reason why poor people have bad diets
and a lot of high diabetes shit like that
and obesity is cause their life sucks
and they don't want their food to suck
their food is some of the only pleasure
that yet. So they need
sweet shit. They fried shit.
They eat like fucking unhealthy shit
cause that's why does that have to suck to
that could be a reason. You
know the reason could be bad
education. It could be a,
a lack of understanding of the direct
effect that putting poor nutrition in your
body has on you also could be the fact
that poor nutrition is much cheaper than
housing and the access to
it so much easier. You know,
fast food's everywhere.
It's all over the place.
You can't just get a salad and you can't
just drive down the street and get her
super healthy salad, desert
dessert, maybe call it. Yeah.
Thinking about all the different places,
whether it's a Taco bell or fucking,
you know, Mcdonald's or Burger
King or Wendy's, how many
of those you see Bam, Bam,
Bam, Bam, Bam when you're
driving down the normal streets.
But how many like salad places, how
many places that sell, you know,
spinach smoothies? I mean, how
many of those, the, the access is,
is for, especially for poor
people, it's not that good.
No,
it's atrocious as a of fact.
And the other thing is vetted vegetables
and fruit are pretty expensive.
Like that's the,
exactly what you were saying.
Yeah. You know, talked to a poor person
about shopping at whole foods. What? Yeah,
no, I can't afford that shit. Yeah, yeah.
It's a mess. It's a mess. So it's a,
it's also a kind of a weird trick, you
know, if you think about it that way,
I mean, what's the best way to keep people
poor, making poor when they're young.
You know, Megan port, keeping involved
with a bunch of other poor people,
wrap them up with poor people,
have poor people around them all the time
and then do nothing to help change it
and you're going to get
a lot of poor people.
That's a good way to keep poor people.
She wanted to keep a
supply of poor people.
Now I'm not insinuating that
there's some sort of a, uh, a, uh,
some sort of a conspiracy to
make sure that people are poor.
I don't believe that.
But what I do believe that if
anybody really wanted to change it,
they would do something different
than what we're already doing.
Well,
you know,
that thing about the upward mobility is
America has failed the American dream.
Basically America's 16th in the world,
in the American dream.
That meaning like jump basically
class jumping, like going from La,
uh,
you know,
lower middle class to middle class or
middle class to upper middle class or like
it's, it's and it's getting
lowered. Used to be way higher. We,
I think we used to be number one.
So is that it's far like the percentage
of people that do it? Is that what it is?
Yeah.
Per capita or whatever? Well that's
fucked. What's number one now?
I think like Denmark, maybe Denmark,
Denmark or Germany, Denmark,
Germany or Japan. I feel like I
could be wrong but, but uh, but yeah,
it's like if you want the American,
I had a buddy that had a girlfriend from
Denmark and um, the uh, fell in love,
all that good stuff. And uh, he, uh,
went back with her to Denmark and he
had so many problems like visa problems,
issues. Beth centration very,
very difficult for him to,
I don't know if he married her,
I'm not sure. But I remember him,
I ran into him like after the process,
like was sort of in the middle of it,
embroiled in it. He was like, it was
really hard. It's really hard to get,
or they don't want people just coming
over there because they have an
unbelievably smooth system.
Like yeah,
you can't be a criminal and you can't
kind of a record. You can't be a bad guy.
You can't like, they want, you know, and
then they're also, they their, their uh,
their system is so nice
and so well set up.
Yeah. They're not on. So bring
us your tired, your poor.
They don't want to meet Mike.
Bring us your clean, efficient.
Yeah.
When you see like countries like Iceland
that I've like really fucking done a
good job of organizing their country.
They dealt with a financial crisis and
then they fucking went after the bankers.
Yeah. That's the best suit. Them,
lock them all up, kicked them all out.
And you look at that like as a,
you know, sort of a microcosm.
It's a small country in
comparison to the United States.
Small in comparison to California,
you know,
but what they did is not
just admirable but possible.
Like someone from somewhere on
earth in 2004 being a human being.
Yeah.
Who speaks a language
that the people around him on in her
understand and they figured it out.
They decided and Vince one
another. Yeah. That was the best.
I mean that's enough. One of the things
you've just got to get lucky early.
You got to get lucky.
The 18 hundreds that you get a good
fucking dude and then that just indoors,
but they're subject to the same sort of
deal that we are over here really. Right.
They're subject to
corruption and bribery and,
and people being unethical somehow or
another. They figured it out though.
But I think, I feel like it's
probably lower over there.
I think America does some shit like that.
Like I think America fucking
breeds it's, it's, yeah.
I mean like we've talked about it before.
It's like there's something
about America's the last
on conquered land on the
earth.
This was it.
So the people here and capitalism is a
real fucking like elbow fro and shit.
Yeah. A lot of elbow throwing
that gets your space. Yeah.
And at this point it's like,
I don't know how you feel about money,
but I feel like at a certain
point it just becomes,
if you have a certain amount of money,
it just becomes about your collecting
carnival tickets. It's like, motherfucker,
you don't need any more of these tickets,
but people want to win.
It's the only way to keep score.
Well,
yeah.
Well I was talking about this recently
that if you see a guy who's worth like a
hundred billion dollars,
but he's fucking completely miserable.
He's on antidepressants and
his life's fallen apart.
His wife left him and he's fucking
suicidal. You still got a Tan,
but it's still worth $100
I, yeah, you got it. That's what
I always say. It's like, dude,
if that was me,
even though that was him and Pete,
and they've done studies
that over a certain amount
of money, happiness doesn't,
you don't get happy over like,
I think it's like 78 grand a year,
but he'll look at you,
Neil Brennan being a successful
comedian and having a good life,
being a happy guy, having a bunch of good
friends and like this fucking failure.
Oh yeah. Once you got in the
bank killing herself, zeroes.
Fuck. Yeah. Just on the way that
the their deathbed fuck. Yeah.
I'm about to go step into
the biggest shot ever made.
I own it flying to my island later today.
I own that.
Sorry about this.
It goes to that private jet thing.
I probably been on four or five private
jets and it's always with pivot or
Chappelle or whatever. But uh, every
time I've been in a private jet,
when you land,
the person who ordered the jet always
points to another bigger jet and goes,
that was the jet I want it to get.
It happens without fit.
It's one of these weird human
quirks where it's like, no,
no thing is enough. You, you're
on a private plane and you,
you're insecure about it.
There was a private plane that you
had your eye on that was better.
Well,
that seems to be like a symptom of the
type of person who makes so much money.
They can afford a private. Exactly.
And that's crazy. Yeah. Crixus
constantly. It's never fucking, it's
just fucking them. We've got to get more,
we're going to get more proud of jets.
That coke thing.
How much is a private jet caused?
It depends where you're going
now.
Maybe mean to own a private
oh to own, I don't know. I
think 5 million or something.
No, I think it's more than
that. Maybe nine in how?
I think it's like 50 how
much does it private check?
It depends what you're getting. If you
get like a g three I don't fucking know.
I'm acting like I know. Well we're,
we're both so far. Gulf stream.
Okay. Check costs. Shh. Keep
it down. I'm trying to stay
light jets. 3 million to 8 million
can take five to eight passengers,
mid size executive jets.
9 million to 16 million can
take up to nine passengers.
Well this guy's got it nailed.
Large executive jets,
17 million can carry 12
passengers more than 4,000 miles.
Wow. Consider the hidden costs
along with the price tag.
That ranges from 6 million to 50
million for a new private jet and Nessus
necessities such as insurance,
fuel,
catering and pilots who are in short
supply aircraft management companies will
take care of these needs for about a
hundred thousand dollars to $200,000 per
year depending on the size and
usage of that yet. Thank you.
Jay K from um,
answers.yahoo.com
yeah, that's a very well
thought out response. Yeah.
So a lot of money. The color,
it's baller category.
If you've got your own three,
it's at least 3 million according to that.
There's a lot of fucking money.
So 3 million that you have
no use for. Well, you know,
if you're some fucking Weirdo Frank
Sinatra character and you don't like being
around people, yeah, you can get in that
plane. And just all of a sudden, Bam,
you land in Atlantic City,
get off and get on stage.
When you see Seinfeld do that. Yeah. It
doesn't rise in flies out that night.
He's got so much cash.
Stop and thinking about that.
Well that's the thing about
Saiful that people don't realize.
You know how they go,
man,
Larry David made $500 million
when they sold it to syndication.
They've sold it two more times since then.
It just wasn't in the paper. How do
you keep selling that? Because the,
because there, because the rights
are only for six years. Yeah.
It's a crazy amount of money.
He's an interesting cat.
And also it doesn't matter.
And it, it's, it's, it's carnival
tickets. It's like you can only buy,
you can only fly private so much.
You can only buy so many cars.
Yeah. But in Jay's, um, in
Jerry's rather a case he's got,
I was thinking of Lenovo for some reason
when I said 70 cars automatically think
of Lennon.
But that's the same thing.
It's like they really love cars
like snow and Jerry Seinfeld Bolts,
fucking love cars. You ever see comedians
in cars getting coffee that way?
It was on last week, the way
that guy talks about cars,
both of them, but the way,
especially the way Seinfeld talks about
cars when he's describing each car that
he's driving, that guy loves.
Absolutely. So for him,
he had to make that much,
but it's good to make that kind of
money because you can't have a hundred
fucking Porsche's unless
you got some [inaudible].
There's that thing where
if you win the lottery,
there's a median happiness level that you
just have built in that you achieve or
do or get can,
can change more than 15 or 20%
sure. And not only that, you can actually
be happy, but it a financial deficit.
But you, if you're at a happiness deficit,
but yet you're financially in the,
in the red, you still are in the black
rather, you're still not feeling good.
Exactly. You know, it's the talk of the
red. Which one? The black, the red is bad.
Yeah, you're still, it's not good. Yeah.
But almost everyone would
choose that over the former.
Well, that's what I say. I always
say people go, you know the we,
we always say like money won't, won't,
can't buy you happiness and everyone goes,
I'll take my chances.
I'll just see about that.
I'm going to do it differently.
My friend.
Well it's cause everybody thinks about
the things that are bothering them,
bothering them in life and for
a lot of people it's financial.
A lot of people it's financial stress.
Like when your when your day to day or
week to week like I remember very clearly
when I first got my first,
when I actually started making money,
when I was living in New York and I got
a development deal and all of a sudden
it was, it wasn't a lot of money
but it was a chunk that boom,
I was given and then I don't have
to worry about money anymore.
Like all of a sudden I can
pay my bills now I have,
I have some money in the bank,
I can go to dinner.
There's this huge way the copper shoulders
a little bit less or it was literally
a week before that. Everything was
a struggle. It's like, what do I,
how many quarters do I have?
I have a $5 and then six quarters,
I got a $6 and then you may like,
I would literally think that way,
but everything was a struggle. How am
I going to come up with $38 for this?
This is 100 bucks at the end of the month.
How am I gonna Afford that?
And it was always in my head
spinning around and distracting me.
And when would that was
removed? I was like, Ooh,
well here's one of the really
good things about money.
It's not necessarily that
money buys you happiness,
but the alleviation of at least one piece
of stress that most of us have to go
through on a daily basis.
Financial stress, that's,
there's something to be said for that.
There is very much,
but what I've noticed is
other things fill the space.
Meaning you just, you have a list
of things you're worried about.
Money goes off the top and then
everybody else moves up because you're,
you're kind of, there's a certain amount
of stress your body just is built for.
Do you know what I mean? Do you really
think that? I do. I mean, I find I've,
it's certainly a thing that like,
I don't,
because people that are rich aren't
naturally hat. You know what I mean?
It doesn't automatically make you happy,
which I feel like proves that
it definitely doesn't
automatically make you happy,
but it doesn't mean that people
who are rich can't be happy.
Oh, I don't think that, I
don't think that at all.
I just think if you're happy and poor,
you're going to be happy and rich
and if you're unhappy and poor,
you're probably going
to be unhappy and ready.
I don't know. Even know if that's
true. That's a generalization.
It's a lot of people happy when they
were in the jars. Asian business,
they start getting rich and then they have
mo money, Mo problems about that, huh?
Yeah. That's well, that's
Puffy I think. Yeah.
I think that people are doing it wrong.
That's what I think. I think, uh,
there's a lot of,
they're doing it wrong out there
and there's a lot of people that are
living lives based almost entirely on
momentum. They just doing things the way
they've always done and they're defining
themselves by their past mistakes.
Yeah. Anna react, they're
reacting to their past mistakes
and they,
they fall into the same traps,
whether it's a gambling trap
or relationship trap. I mean,
how many people do I
know people that they,
they're serial monogamists where
they'll have one crazy super involved
relationship for like six months and
then another crazy super and they go one,
two
stop and go. Like, this is
defeating. This is sort of nuts.
Yeah. Well it's also, they like
immediately take someone in the,
immediately fall deeply in love,
the immediately spend every
minute together and then boom,
you see him next month and where,
where's, where's Wendy? Oh, Wendy's gone.
Who's this? This is Cindy. Oh,
okay. And they know like, okay,
Cindy's through this life
as subtle as shit, man.
You know what I'm talking about those
people, that's like a real common thing.
Right? What was the, what was
the last thing he said? It
needs the new Wendy. Yeah.
Oh absolutely.
But what I was saying is life subtle.
Well, it's also, we, we
seek comfort in patterns.
One of the things that people hate more
than anything is the fear of the unknown.
Yeah. You know, and uh,
that's one of the things that people are
severely lacking and they were lacking
in it. Adventure. You know,
there's something about,
and being in the middle
of doing something,
we have no idea what the fuck is going to
happen. And we were like, wow, this is,
this is kind of wild. This is, this is a
crazy experience. And that's, that's like,
that's important for life
to be involved in things.
You don't know how they're going to
turn out. Not necessarily dangerous,
but something different than
driving to the same fucking Yep.
You know, it hearkens, makes me laugh
is when you'll be on like a busy street,
Ventura or Fairfax or whatever,
and you know,
everyone knows there's a side street and
almost no one takes it because they're
just afraid something fucked up is going
to happen on the side street. It's like,
just go on the site. It's,
it's day, it's light out.
Nothing's going to happen.
But people are so used to like,
let me just stay on Ventura.
I know Ventura,
everything's going to be fun because
people are just naturally sort of fearful
and they seek comfort
in, in, in the in, right
Titian yeah.
They want to eliminate the possibilities.
That's of like a big thing with people.
Like what do people plan for?
They plan for retirement when they get
can stop all this and enjoy their golden
years.
So the idea is that you're
going to alleviate all of
your stress and all of the
unknown, but that's not going to happen.
You're not really alleviating that. The,
the,
the stress of the unknown is just a part
of the wonder and the mystery of life.
You're supposed to embrace that.
It's supposed to embrace that adventure.
And if you do, you find yourself living
in exciting and fascinating life.
And if you don't,
you live the life of a fearful man.
Well that's bill [inaudible] says that's
how he writes new bits. He's just,
I just, he goes, I just try to do
something I've never done before.
Yeah. That's smart. And, and that's how,
and then I usually come up with a
bit about it. I do that as well.
Most of the time I do that just because
I want to do that for life more than I'm
going to try to write bits.
But I do think like when I,
like when I moved to Colorado,
one of the things I thought of when I
was up in his fucking house in the middle
of the woods like this, I'm going to
get a lot of material out of this.
I didn't know it was going to get it
cause a mountain lion ate my fucking dog.
I didn't know it was
going to be like that,
but I thought I was going to
get some material out of this.
Cause it's such a completely different
environment, a different existence,
a different way of looking at the world.
You're looking at the world through this
incredible fucking boundless beauty and
nature around you all the time, you
know? But I just think as a person,
forget about creating
material as a person.
It enhances you and I guess having any
experience at enhances you was going to
make your art better. Yeah. You know,
this weekend I went pig
hunting like I said, and um,
I shot this pig at about five 15.
Okay.
It was getting dark and I
shot this pig on an angle.
There was a hill like this. I
mean fucking super steep, right?
Like the most ridiculous slide ever.
If you were on it,
you can climb up it
and you can climb down,
but you can't stand up right
to go down it. I went down it.
But you have to go on your hands and
knees and there's just a lot of spot.
This would happen. The pig was at the
top. I shot the peg and then the pig,
Tom Doom, doom, doom, doom, doom,
and went maybe three or 400 yards to
the bottom of this incredibly steep hill
and the pigs about 200 pounds.
So now me and Steve Rinella have this
decision to make. We have to figure out,
do we go up with the pig or do figure
out how to get the pig down and then find
another way and access to the road.
So we try two times to,
to latch a rope to the pig
and then drag the rope, uh,
up with a truck. Okay. So we're trying
to pull this Pega, the ropes snaps twice.
So because the rope is resting
up against rocks fucked up.
It didn't break the skin.
I mean they're not bulletproof
obviously cause I came it with a bullet,
but there their skin
is unbelievably dense.
Wild pigs are some of the most durable
and toughest fucking animal ever come
across. Like they have these pigs that
have gotten shot by, you know, like a,
or a rifle.
Bullet goes through their leg and they
see them walking around the next day with
like a hole in their leg and they're
still eating and fighting with each other.
I watched him fight, I watched these
pigs, Duke it out in the, in the bushes.
We couldn't get close
enough to make a shot,
but there were duking it out in the
bushes no more than 10 yards from us.
And they're going after each
other and you look at them,
they've got these giant fucking tusks.
It was all bushes.
So there's no clean shot to hit them.
But it's like,
these are like Jurassic animals. They're
ferocious, crazy. We think of them as,
you know, pigs as like, you know, oh,
there's a little cute little blankie.
Literally teeth bigger than your fuck.
You finger is growing out of their bottom
lip and they're these huge tank like
animals.
We saw regularly,
we saw a 450 pound pigs.
I mean, they're enormous.
Giant, muscular, lien,
beefy fucking animals.
And so you're seeing these things
all around you, uh, in this, in this,
in this crazy area.
And it just gives you this
ridiculous respect for nature.
Ridiculous respect for this, this
world you've chosen to enter into and,
and have this little adventure.
So this, this pig gets shot, okay,
goes tumbling down at after the
rope breaks twice we decide, okay,
this rope is not gonna
be able pull his pig up.
The rope is rubbing up against rocks on
the way up. And because it's so steep,
I mean,
it's literally just grinding back and
forth on all these rocks and the rope just
can't take it. It keeps
snapping. So we did that.
We talked to the guide and the guide says,
let's, uh, drag the pig to the bottom,
let it tumble to the bottom,
push it all the way down to the creek bed.
And then you guys could drag it out from
the creek bed to the road because it's,
it's pretty much down where the old
downhill the whole way. So you push it.
So it gets to a certain point in time,
we realize this is not going to work.
It's hours later, it's pitch black
out. We see nothing but stars.
And we have these little
headlight things on her hand.
And we started hearing footsteps around
us. There's mountain lions in there, many,
many, many, many mountain lions.
Like they have at least 16 of them on
one trail camera that they got last week.
So one trail camera got at least 16
different big cats that live in this area
and we're pushing a bloody pig.
Okay. And so we get to the,
there's a picture of it.
So it gets to a point where we,
I'm smiling a little too hard for animal
rights. People change that quick. But, um,
so we get to a point where we realized,
okay,
we're going to have to do some about this
pig. So what Steve, I was with this guy,
Steve Rinella, who's the host
of the show, meat eaters,
a master hunter outdoorsman. Who by the
way, I like to think I'm in good shape,
but I'm in good shape. If you
want to do Jujitsu, all right,
or you want to kickbox doing, let's not
like walking up hills. Like, I'm like,
that guy's a fucking Billy goat. I'm
a bitch. Do you want an hired? No,
I do a kettle bells. I do a lot of body
weight squats. I do a lot of kickboxing,
a lot of, um, in good shape
for that kind of shit.
But when you're hiking for like six,
seven hours in a row, I'm exhausted.
We're going up hills all the time. This
motherfucker is barely breaking a sweat.
I never felt more like a bitch in my
whole life, but he doesn't rub it in.
I appreciate that.
But anyway,
so we decided that we had to gut this
thing and then we had to carry it out in
pieces. And so we're at the bottom of
this fucking hill. It's pitch black out.
You look up,
you see a majestic blanket of stars in
this guy because to hone ranches way up
like 45 plus minutes from Bakersfield,
there's nothing out there, man.
It's just stars. There's
no light pollution. It's
just fucking beautiful man.
But we're dragging this pig downhill
and we're sliding and I'm slipping and
falling and I got a half a pig on my
shoulder. Like we cut the pig in half,
he got one half, I got another half.
We took the head off and the spine out.
And so I have a literally a flexible
half of pig skin and a ham and a shoulder
and he has the same and each
one of us is probably carrying,
I'd say at least 70 or 80 man.
I'm just guessing. I don't know.
It's probably something along that.
And we're going down hill with these
fucking things sliding and I'm like,
I could die. Like it's dark out. I
can't see what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm holding a flashlight.
He's got a thing on its forehead.
Is there a guide with you? Nope. Not
right now. No, not at this point in time.
I mean,
we're just,
we have to figure out how to get to the
bottom and then go from the creek bed,
um, down to the road. Well, you know,
we're going probably a mile and we're
going in the dark downhill carrying 100
pounds of pig and it's crazy.
And while we're doing a hearing footsteps,
we're here in snap.
You hear like a twig snaps behind you
and turn around and you're like, oh shit.
You know, were armed,
you know, and you know,
we're making a lot of noise and most
animals are not going to fuck with people
in the first place. It's just a little
too dangerous. It's weird proposition.
You don't know what the fuck people
bring. People Bring Bang sticks, you know.
But while this is all going on and
I don't know what's going to happen,
I'm thinking this is a wild
scenario because I don't
know what's going to happen.
Yeah.
I hope I get to the end and I throw the
pig in the back of the truck and want to
go, whew. That was
exhausting. But we did it,
but I don't know because I'm sliding
downhill sometimes and I'm falling and I'm
like, this is, this is fucking,
this is a god damn adventure.
But when it was all over like
the next day I'm charged,
you're charged because of that. Like
your whole body is like, you know, like,
like because you went through this crazy
adventure and it didn't know what the
fuck was going to happen. Yeah.
But then came out of it. Okay. You,
you feel more alive.
Yeah. The other thing is you see
more. Yeah. In those situations,
because I always find like even with like,
I don't know if it's a guy
thing or a human thing,
I don't notice my surroundings
after like my house.
I don't even, I just see the couch and
the TV. I don't see tape. I don't see it.
It just, it all just goes away
because it's so repetitive.
Right,
right.
It's like when people are in their car
and all of sudden they find themselves
home.
I don't even remember it.
Yeah, exactly. And the, and when you're
in a situation where it's all new,
you actually like, oh fuck, I have
to pay attention. I don't have,
well you have to pay attention because
you might die. But you're also just like,
you're just more aware.
Right. So even if you like, we forgot
about a life or death situation,
I wasn't really, I mean, completely
exaggerating if I say it does tuition,
but it was certainly dangerous.
I mean,
there was a lot of slipping and falling
and sliding downhill while you're
carrying all this weight. It's dangerous.
You could get hurt, you get hurt,
you really hurt yourself. But even
just going somewhere you've never been,
and exploring some new place
you've never been to, you know,
go to some new city where you've
never been in. Check out the sites.
All that stuff is enriching.
Yeah. Anything you're doing,
we can get out of your daily box
and also just get out of the
same brain loop. The same,
just the same synapses are firing.
You know what I find really fascinating
when you go to places and the people in
those places have a different mentality.
Like you can go to New
Jersey and New Jersey,
we'll have a specifically aggressive
type of mentality and then you can go
somewhere in Iowa where people
like you know, down home,
Midwest friendly folks and you're like,
it's so weird that they have
like very specific ways behaving.
Like if you only knew humans, it's
like if humans were like, you know,
a type of animal,
like what's an ostrich?
Like if you meet it all their
fucking very aggressive,
don't go near ostriches or
oh they're super healthy.
They'll give you a homemade pie.
How can it be the same animal in the wild?
But with people you literally,
we really do find pockets of behavior
that's very consistent and very unique.
Yeah.
And it goes back to the thing of like,
why would you ever go to a city and
go like, Phoenix is a good example.
Or you know,
minute Minneapolis that's so fucking
cold or so fucking hot and you just go,
how did people decide to
stay here? Yeah, no shit.
It's a weird thing of
like that 150 years ago,
some charismatic guy
probably just convinced like,
no, fuck it. We're staying here. Some
Dick slinging wizard. Yeah. Just like, no,
we're fucking stay in here.
And then they just figured out tray
trade routes and all that shit.
Like just whatever. There's a lake
there so they can, yeah. Yeah.
This is a good place to park their car.
There's just shit.
There's like good facilities.
Well the crazy thing about
Phoenix is that Phoenix,
they did that shit before
they had ac. Like I, I like
Phoenix. I, I matter of fact,
I love it. I was just there last
weekend. I love hot weather. Yeah.
Phoenix is a great fucking town man.
Cause people are coolest shit.
They're super friendly.
They're, they're fun.
They don't take themselves too seriously.
They're intelligent. You know, like I,
that standup live, do you do that
place? Fuck, that's a great club.
That's a fucking great. But how did
those people ever get there? With no AC?
Yeah, on. I honestly don't. I be
curious as to like what the, how.
I guess it's kind of one of those like
Jared diamond, guns, germs and steel,
things like the evolution
of American cities there.
There are obvious ones. Chicago's
on a lake. You can go through the,
but then there's once it's like Phoenix.
I have no fucking idea how it
ended up there. Too Hot to leave.
They got there and they're like, it's
too hot to go anywhere. We can't.
We shouldn't go.
We won't be able to make it out by sun up.
This is getting this lake,
this lake and cool off and
then we'll figure it out when
it, oh, there's no light.
There's no way. There are no
lakes on a stream and this cactus.
Exactly. Cool. My balls off.
That's why they're on the outside.
I got to get out of here buddy. Neil
Brennan. Get the fuck Outta here.
Go check Neal Brennan Online. Ladies
and gentlemen, follow him on Twitter.
It's n e a l B. R. E. N. N.
A. N. So just fine buddy.
Oh, always a good time. And Neil
Brennan, women and Black Dudes,
you can buy it now on comedy
central direct, right.
A CES director at see doc.
Yeah. Um, and catch it.
It was going to do a repeat. I'm
not sure when. I should know.
I'm sure the comedy central websites
will probably tell you or somewhere you'd
be able to juggle it,
but enjoy the comedy and go see Neil live.
He tool is,
he's a very funny young man.
He's got unique ideas.
God you fucking freaks and a,
we will be back tomorrow.
Tomorrow I have John Hackleman,
the Great John Hackleman trainer
of chocolate, Dell and many,
many great fighters who was a really
fun, cool, interesting dude. I've been a,
not just a fan of his,
but a friend of his for years.
I really liked that guy and I'm excited
to be talking with him tomorrow.
It's gonna be a lot of fun.
Uh, and then Peter Shift,
the economists will be here on Wednesday.
Uh,
thank you to stamps.com.
Go to stamps.com and use the code word
j r e to get your $110 bonus offer or
bass,
right sweetie,
and thanks also to legal zoom.com make
sure you enter Rogan in the referral box
at checkout for more savings,
legal zoom.com thanks.
Also to [inaudible] Dot
Com that's o.N , n. I. T.
Use the code word Rogan and save 10% off
any supplements are right you fucking
sleek and sexy bitches. We will
see you all tomorrow. Until then,
may Odin praise you.
Bless you.
Whatever he does what is owed
and do praise, Odin, big kiss.